This is Jocko podcast number 24 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink
and our guests tonight is Jody Mitak.
Jodi is a former Canadian army soldier and sniper who served in Afghanistan.
He now serves as an elected member of the Ottawa to city council.
You got second place in a show called the amazing race.
He authored the best selling book about his experiences.
He's a husband and a dad,
and beyond all that,
Jody is a real hero or an absolute inspiration to anybody that knows his story,
which is what we'll be talking about tonight.
Welcome to the show,
Jodi.
Thank you Jocko.
Did I miss anything?
Jocko.
Mega Fan.
Thanks man.
I appreciate that.
Also with us is Echo Charles.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Now before we dig into your book.
Yeah,
I wanted to start off with an excerpt of a poem
by Richard Kipling and it's called the young British soldier,
and I think this is a little bit appropriate since Candida's a form or part of
the Commonwealth of England and now part of the Commonwealth.
And while Kipling was never actually a soldier,
he did attend the United Service College in England,
which kind of prepared young men for the army,
although he never joined.
But he did spend many years abroad and the British colonies.
And he also lost his only son,
John in world war one at the battle of Loos in September of 1915
whether it was just about a hundred thousand casualties in a matter of days.
And John Kipling was last seen lurching through the mud,
blindly crying out in agony
after his face had been ripped apart by an exploding shell.
And this poem that I'm about to read a part of it is not about world war one,
it's about the British wars that took place from the 1830s till the early 19
hundreds in a part of the world called Afghanistan.
Hm.
And here was this a latter part of that poem
when first under fire
and your wishful to duck,
don't look nor take heed at the man that has struck be you're living at trust.
To Your luck in March to your front,
like a soldier front,
front,
like a soldier.
If your officer's dead in the sergeants,
look white.
Remember it's a ruined to run from a fight.
So take open order,
lie down and sit tight and wait for supports like a soldier.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Like a soldier
when you're wounded and left on Afghanistan's planes and the women come out to
cut up what remains?
Just roll to your rifle and blow out your brains and go to your God like a
soldier.
Go,
go,
go like a soldier.
I think that poems sets a tone
for what kind of a place Afghanistan can be.
Yeah,
it's been a while.
So to hear that.
Yeah,
that last line's not,
not a joke either.
No,
it isn't.
Um,
and we're to get there on your book here in a minute.
Your book is called unflinching.
This is the book right here.
And I kind of made that connection with the unflinching part.
You've been a sniper.
You obviously can't be flinching when you're taking a shot.
Right?
And this whole thing kicks off the first chapter,
which the name of the first chapter is awesome because this is something that I
believe is something that a lot of people have.
I know,
I damn sure did.
The first chapter is called the soldier in the child
and I think that describes a lot of people that join the military.
Yeah.
It's the thing that's in there.
It's,
they're born with it.
You were born with it.
I know.
I was born with it.
Yeah.
It's all I ever wanted to do.
It's all I want to do.
Believe me.
Now your mom,
how did she feel about all that?
She resisted,
uh,
like any eighties mom,
right?
You're,
how old are you again?
44 so you're a little older than I am,
but
my mom,
being a foster kid,
read all the books and all the books at the time said,
boy,
you should play with barbies and girls who play with Tonka trucks and treat them
gender neutral and blah,
blah,
blah.
But guess what?
If you put boys in a room and girls in a room with toys,
the boys play a Tonka trucks and the girls play with the barbies.
I just,
the way it is.
Yeah.
No,
matter of fact,
my son,
I had two,
two daughters that were young and our house and I didn't want them.
I'm not going to have them have all these barbies.
I don't even know where they came from,
but they showed up at my house and he goes,
what?
My son was born and I was all worried,
oh,
he's going to be playing with barbies.
That kid will hit kid didn't care about barbies.
He didn't care about anything that had wheels on it.
Yeah.
It's just,
and it's boys and girls are different.
They're just different.
And,
and,
uh,
you know what,
I know lots of women that are great soldiers.
I'm not saying that they don't have it,
but mom wanted,
you know,
a no guns,
uh,
GI Joes,
but no,
you know,
couldn't keep the weapons.
Um,
and,
you know,
and I,
and I love her for it because who knows who I would have been if she had,
maybe if she had fostered it,
it would have,
it would have fizzled out.
I don't know.
Um,
but yeah,
all I want to do with soldier since I was,
since I was little
boy.
So your mom had that attitude and then along came a uncle Jim.
Yup.
Uncle Jim.
Tell,
tell us a little bit about uncle Joe.
I mean,
I just saw him the last weekend actually.
He lives in Victoria where we're Mr Echo was born.
And um,
he,
when when you're a child,
right,
there's nothing more impressionable than a three year old,
really.
Right.
When I was three,
he would back then,
uh,
if you were in uniform,
you could ride the train for free and get the bus for free.
And so he would ride the train in uniform when he had his,
uh,
leave and he'd show up at the house and he'd bring me teddy bears.
And I was like,
this is obviously the coolest dude ever.
And whatever he does,
I want to do it.
And he would tell stories about what he did,
you know,
and he was,
he was an infantry soldier,
same regiment that I joined.
And,
uh,
and that was the seed.
I assume no one really knows.
This is just family lore,
right.
Where,
because mom didn't like it.
Dad was a blue collar auto worker.
Um,
his dad was in the army,
but it was like conscripted into the Serbian border guard when the,
when the,
when the German army showed up,
he basically threw his hands up,
was like,
Yep,
I'm cool.
Don't shoot.
Um,
you know,
mom's dad apparently was in the army,
but no one knows because he died when she was 10.
Um,
no one's really sure what he did.
You know,
apparently he was in Korea,
but there's no record of it.
So anyway,
it's just,
it was there.
And Jim,
I think was the catalyst that's,
that sparked it sparked it it when I was just a young,
yeah,
little impressionable boy that happens now when you got to be a teenager,
you know,
you kind of sounded in the book,
you sound like,
yes.
You sound like a teenager.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
and I mean just to go here.
In your book you say I was a loner who didn't fit in.
I still dreamt of being in the army probably because I wanted to belong to
something.
Yeah,
and it was definitely clear.
I didn't belong in school.
I hated school.
I hate especially cause when you get to high school,
I don't know how you guys five,
I've heard you talk a little bit about it.
It sounded like you had the same issues.
Like definitely couldn't connect with any year teachers.
The only teacher I remember I had this teacher,
I forget his name,
but he was Scottish originally and he was my history teacher.
Like the only subject I cared about was history really.
And he would tell stories about everything else he ever did in life before he
was a teacher.
And I was like,
okay,
this guy actually has some shit that I need to hear because he's been around the
world and he's done everything.
The rest of them.
I joined,
I became a teacher at a college and this is how you type.
And I'd be like,
why am I even here?
What am I doing here doing math?
I,
you know,
snipers,
we eat ballistic church for breakfast and math was useless to me in high school.
And uh,
yeah,
I just,
the last thing I wanted to be was in school and I've actually cause this,
this was the the nineties,
right?
So that was still when you could quit school to join the army.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm just going to quit school and join the army.
And my parents like basically had to beg me to stay.
They let me join the reserves,
which in Canada is called the militia and it's like once a week and a weekend a
month now.
Like you can do that,
but don't quit school.
Finished school.
Alright.
But it was like completely against my will,
but they find the got you.
They finally let you join.
You joined them on their show.
Right.
And then,
but,
but you weren't,
still weren't active duty.
Well,
the militia in Canada,
you can be called up to active duty,
but it's not like we chatted a little bit about this on the way here where you
guys have a different system here cause yours is much bigger.
But also like the militia and Canada was the military before World War Two
basically.
So regiments were local,
uh,
was a part time thing.
You know,
it was Kinda like,
it was the,
what does that,
what do they call it,
the citizen soldier and a,
the regular army was just there to kind of give them an enemy force and,
and take care of the,
the,
the machine guns and the howitzers the doesn't there.
So that we had at the time,
and it wasn't til after World War Two that it flipped because it was,
you know,
the Cold War started and all that jazz.
So,
you know,
um,
at any time the regular army now into the 90s could say,
you know what,
we need 10 reserve soldiers to,
to fill in a platoon here.
And if you could volunteer.
And I remember when I showed up to my,
my reserve unit,
the resurgence sewing private stripes onto their uniform because they were
called up to the regular army.
But you're not as sergeant,
you're like,
you're qualified because to keep guys in the reserves,
they promote them faster.
But when you go work with the regs,
like they're not going to call you a sergeant you've been in as long as Corporal
Smith.
Ah,
private stripes bitch.
So,
uh,
but,
but guys,
guys,
guys would fight each other to get those slots though.
Cause there was nothing better,
more honorable than to deploy with a reg force regimen.
Absolutely.
And Go,
you know,
peacekeeping.
But you know,
there's still a few gun fights here and there.
I thought this was cool.
And the book,
you talked about this here,
you're basically starting bootcamp and you say you just get your haircut.
Yeah.
Get your head shaved
for the first time.
Once the Barbara was done,
I studied myself in his mirror.
I barely recognize the young man staring back at me.
The eyes were the same,
but everything else was different.
I wasn't Jody Mitak lay about loner highschool,
good for nothing.
Another floundering adolescent with no ambition and no life plan.
That kid was lying under a pile of hair on the floor.
Looking back at me was Jody Mitic soldier in training?
Goosebumps.
So legit.
Yeah.
Well,
so I had at the time,
lethal weapon two was my favorite movie ever.
So I had like tempted straight Mel Gibson hair.
Oh Dude,
it was glorious.
Oh,
you should've seen it.
A Max.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Food,
walking around smoking cigarettes and pretending.
Yeah.
Anyway,
just being ridiculous.
But
you know,
it happened to me again recently because I had grown my beard out and I had a
bit of,
I had some long hair and I did,
I did it.
I shaved the beard down to nothing and I went to the barber who usually does his
best to give me a little bit of length but still make me look professional.
And I said,
I want you to give me a number one all around.
That's what I'm talking about.
And this was just,
this was just like a month ago and you know,
he,
she did all that and you know,
your skin feels cold cause now the air is on it.
And I looked in the mirror and it was almost the same feeling.
I went,
oh,
oh there he is.
I was like,
there's that soldier.
And I remember the feeling because it was,
the guy's name was Marco.
He was this Italian guy who cut my hair and he couldn't believe it because he
had fostered this ridiculous mullet for the last two years.
And now I said shave it off.
Cause I showed him a picture of a marine.
I said I want to look like this guy.
And when he shaved it and then
it was like,
I was at the starting line of,
of like the biggest race I'd ever gonna to run in my life.
And,
and all I could think about was getting to the end and being successful.
It's full.
And it changed my life,
man.
It changed my life.
Yeah.
You know what,
one thing that,
cause when I was a kid,
I was into,
this is going a little bit tangential,
but I was into the hardcore scene on the east coast hardcore music.
That's what I grew up with.
And it was like,
yeah,
shaved heads getting after it.
But one of my best friend at the time,
he's like,
listen,
you know,
we're part of this where there's nowhere to hide.
You can't hide behind your bangs.
It's all right there.
You gotta face yourself nice.
And it also strips away,
you know,
any kind of,
I mean,
hair is basically,
uh,
what's that word?
It's basically for show,
I mean this is where hair is.
It has no purpose other than I look good.
So let's just go ahead and remove that.
I don't care what I look like,
I'm here to win.
So yeah,
I guess that might explain my haircut.
It's so
I'm glad you picked that.
Sent that,
that paragraph.
Because when I did this a month ago,
it was when I started my training for a bodybuilding show.
I decided to do and I think I just like,
I was having trouble getting into it,
you know,
uh,
I know how to do everything.
I know how to eat well.
I know how to work out and when we're going outside,
I was like 16 but I just wasn't,
it wasn't clicking,
you know?
And I went to the barber and I did that and it was like the switch went off,
boom.
And there it was,
it was like,
oh,
I'm back at that starting line.
I'm going to be 40 in January,
so I want a six pack before I'm 40 I don't know.
Since I got blown up,
I haven't had one that's been 10 years.
Right on.
All right,
so now we get to this next section.
Now you're kind of learning about what the army's like and here's some stuff
that you said about it.
There was a system for everything in the army,
a way to stand and a way to sit,
a way to dress in a way to sleep.
There's also a way to a system for how to properly eat at the mess hall.
Our routine was an endless monotonous cycle.
We woke up,
made our cots,
folded our sleeping bags and the exact way we'd been taught once the tent wasn't
shape,
it was on to barrack spar barrack boxes.
We had to lay them out as instructed with everything in its proper place,
whether it made sense or not.
We had to stand beside our kit at cots.
Everyone perfectly still as the officer did inspection at the time.
I thought that so much of this discipline was overkill.
Why did we have to stand at attention when the officer was on the other side of
the tent looking at some other dude's cotton kit?
Why did our Barix boxes have to be identical?
It took me a couple of years to figure out that the skills they were drilling
into us are actually really important for a combat leader.
If you can't still stand still long enough for morning inspection,
how can your commanders trusts you to hold your posts during a mortar barrage?
How will lead or no,
he can count on you to be a useful soldier if you can't even follow through on
an order meant to keep you and your comrades safe,
even if you don't know what at the time.
All these drills were training me to put self discipline above my instinct to
flinch or flee when everything in me told me to break my posture,
to stand down.
I learned to obey a different order.
Instead,
it was basic training,
but I was assimilating some important skills that would later make me a better
sniper.
Now I talk about discipline all the time.
Yeah,
and that's obviously why I honed in on this because you kind of captured the
kinds of things that they're teaching you,
discipline,
they're teaching you disciplined eight.
If you don't make that connection for all you young troopers out there that are
getting ready to join the military,
there's a purpose.
There's a reason behind it.
Okay.
A definite purpose
and you know that's part of my book is the book that I wrote with leaf.
You know one of the chapters is called discipline equals freedom.
Yeah.
There's another chapter in there,
it happens to be called cover and move.
Yeah.
And you know,
we relate it to everything we do.
To me there's no other tactic.
And again I had to call this out in your book and by the way,
I'm reading your book right now.
Yeah.
And I was trying to figure out how to do this.
Like should I say,
okay,
can you read this section?
And then I thought to myself,
okay,
it's going to be different for you to hear it coming from someone else to hear
the words.
And when I looked up at you after reading that first section I was like,
he just enjoyed that I did.
Yeah,
because you're hearing it,
you can't,
you can never hear it when you hear yourself read it your each like I dunno,
I have my own reaction cause they're my words.
But especially from someone like,
like you,
someone who shared relatively common experiences and you know,
I was a sniper team leader.
You were a,
you were a task force leader.
And for us to have a similar reaction to the same types of things is,
it's very interesting for me to see as well to see for someone like Jocko read
the same thing that I went through and go,
yes,
exactly because you got it.
It took me a couple of years to realize,
like I said,
why,
why am I standing here?
This is a stupid,
is this cause just go out,
let's just go with and train.
When you are training bitch,
you're learning how to do what you're told and you're learning how to back.
Cause if you take off from your barracks box,
well guess who's going to pay for it?
The guy next to you and you know,
beyond doing what you're told,
even in that paragraph you pointed out,
look the the,
the inspectors look in the other direction.
You could easily break your posture.
Yeah.
You know he's not going to see you.
He's never going to catch you.
But guess what?
You held the line.
Yeah.
You held the line and that's what you're learning is that no matter what,
no matter if people are looking at or not,
you're going to do your job.
That's your duty.
It's your job,
it's the job,
right?
It's the job and people,
what's the,
what makes a good soldier at someone who who understands their job is to be that
soldier and I know,
okay,
I know what I'm saying and you know what I'm saying.
But you got to go through that to really understand it and me and you can give
advice all day to people like new new guys.
We get when you tweeted out I was coming,
oh I'm getting ready to go on selection.
I'm getting ready to go to,
I want to be a sniper.
I'm joining the infantry.
What do I do?
I can give you advice all day.
Jocko can give you advice all day,
but man,
there's some things you just got to learn on your own and that's that standing
there with your boots polished at full at,
you know,
standing at the chow wondering why you had to iron your shirt again is going to
help you later on.
When you're under enemy machine,
gun fire and mortars are coming down.
Trust me,
that Shit's going to help
you,
but you're going to learn that on your own.
Now back to cover and move.
Uh,
here you go.
Talking about covered move in our pairs,
one guy would move forward while the other guy would shoot to provide cover.
The mover would yell moving and jump up and move forward.
About three steps saying in his head up,
he sees me down while his partner covered him at down the mover would take
cover,
going to ground,
taking up a firing position and yelling,
covering once in position.
Then his partner would move forward the same way.
The idea was to always have a foot on the ground,
which means one soldier is covering while the other is moving.
Boom.
And you just had to break that out on your own team at work now in the civilian
sector,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
we had lunch and uh,
the best thing I got out of reading your book,
my transition was a weird one.
Okay.
Politics is not business,
but there are some business aspects in that I'm now dealing with people that
aren't,
you know,
I've,
I'm used to working in small teams with people that are professionals at what we
do.
You know,
snipers.
And even though I was 10 years ago,
that's basically my last real working environment.
That's what you know,
is,
that's what I know.
So if even if I'm the boss and you're my sniper and I go,
Echo,
I need you to take up this position.
I can go away,
come back,
that position's taken.
But when you're dealing with civilian staff who have never operated in that kind
of,
are we say operated,
they've never worked in that kind of environment.
If I tell him to do something and walk away,
you better come back and check because they're not used to that kind of freedom.
Cause it's disciplined.
But it's you're giving them,
I'm giving you the freedom to do the job I gave you.
You don't need me to double check that you took up the proper sniper position
and then also the fire and the cover and move the foot on the ground.
I realized after reading your book and went,
so Jocko just basically was like,
listen dummy bay.
That's how I felt.
I felt like a dummy.
I'm like,
of course I should have implemented this in the office.
My people were operating in silos cause I had my,
my,
cause I'm the sports commissioner for the city.
So I had a sports,
one of my assistants was on sports,
one of my assistants was on the policy and one of my assistants was on um,
con constituency work and that's where you deal with the,
the,
the voters who call it.
But none of them were talking to each other.
And I was only talking to them sporadically.
So I said,
okay guys,
from starting today,
I didn't tell them why though.
I wasn't like,
I wasn't going to say,
Hey,
this Guy Jocko gave me an idea.
I said,
hey guys,
I got an idea
from now on cc,
you're going to see,
see him and he,
see him back whenever you send an email.
And then I'm going to CCU and you're going to see,
see me within that week,
our productivity,
you like 100% improvement because now instead of everyone,
it was just aware of what the others were and it,
and there are things that I already know,
but now I got to learn to apply them in my civilian life because I'm not working
with highly trained snipers anymore.
I'm working with people that are good at their jobs,
but not necessarily the way that I expected them to be.
And it,
you know,
there's,
there's so much,
we were talking about it right before we pressed record about why is your,
the last podcast was the art of war.
And,
and to us it's kind of like a Duh,
you know,
Joe Rogan says all the time,
it's a Duh,
that's a Duh thing.
But there's so much you can take from that book and up.
There's a reason why fortune 500 CEOs keep it in their desk because you can
apply a lot of what Sun Tzu said 3000 years ago to right now.
And just your daily life to your interactions with your kids,
interactions with your,
your boss or your subordinates or your supplier or your,
you know,
your,
your colleagues.
It's all right there.
It's just,
you got to translate it,
you know,
uh,
it's not difficult ground.
It's,
you know,
it's a position you have to take on a,
on an issue.
So,
yeah,
like I,
it's a trip to me this whole life,
this whole thing.
It's uh,
it's human nature that,
that thread of human nature runs through from 2,500 years ago.
It's on Su through war,
through life,
through business,
through the relationships that you now have with your kids.
Yeah.
It's everywhere.
Kids
now you,
since you were a militia,
you actually went back to school after you went to bootcamp.
So you get back to school.
And this is very typical.
Before militia training,
I'd been so bored at school and found everything tedious and pointless.
But after eight weeks of soldier training,
school seemed like a breeze.
I started arriving on time and paying attention to the lessons in the military.
You can direct your career according to your aptitudes and interests,
so I decided to do the same at school.
Instead of taking classes I hated,
I picked ones I knew I would enjoy.
My grades improved because I was doing more of what I wanted to do.
For the first time.
I had discipline and self direction and instead of all that energy being
repressed or coming out in the wrong way,
I had focus.
I went from being a loner and keeping to myself to becoming more outgoing and
popular at school.
That discipline goes a long way.
It really goes a long at,
see,
I went to college after I'd been in the seal teams for eight years,
no,
sorry,
10 years.
So when I went to college I was like,
oh,
bring it,
bring it on.
I've got to study every little thing you say and I'm going to know it better
than that,
but I found I was a better student.
Oh.
After going through bootcamp.
Doubt about it.
Uh,
and basic training.
It just like learning became easier.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Even if I didn't want to know what they were talking about.
Yeah.
That's something that the army imposes on you is they'll teach you something and
for the first time you,
cause in civilian world when you're a kid,
they go,
you've got to learn this and you don't study.
And next thing you know,
you don't really know it.
And then you take the test and you fail and you're like,
oh,
I'm not smart items.
I'm an idiot.
And the army like,
no,
you will learn this then and then,
and then you learn it and you say,
oh,
okay.
That's how I learned.
I actually have to apply myself and study and now I'm going to get an A.
Yeah.
Which is awesome.
So then now you still weren't active in the military,
you went to get your factory work on.
Yeah.
Well I was,
I was as active as I had to be.
Uh,
cause it's,
you know,
it's part time.
Right,
right.
And then,
you know,
there was a girl,
just beautiful Russian girlfriend.
And,
um,
you know,
dad got me a great paying job,
but I'll let you,
I'll let you say it.
Yeah,
no,
it's good.
And then find,
you were like,
okay,
I'm ready to you.
You worked in that factory situation for so long.
Then you said,
I'm going to go,
well it's about a year and I was making money that like,
it was like 25 bucks an hour.
Dang.
I was 19.
Was it 1986 I think.
And uh,
I hate it.
I'm sorry dad,
if you're,
if you hear this,
cause he got me the job,
but it was his parent company because he was in union,
he was in the,
we had the Canadian auto workers down here.
It's the United auto workers.
And uh,
just it just,
it just,
it was soul crushing for me,
for me and nothing against guys that can do it.
There are guys that have worked there 30 years.
They put the same rivet in over and over and over again for eight hours a day.
And they're masters at it and they love it and they punch their card and they go
home and they do their thing wasn't for Jodi.
Uh,
no.
So you get back now you go full active duty.
Yes.
You become a soldier by profession.
So I do what we call a transfer to the regular force and the,
and then on top of that,
usually you're supposed to go through training again,
depending on your level of experience because I was only both three years,
so I should have gone through what,
what back,
what's called battle school and that's,
that's the regular armies battle school to become an infantry soldier.
For whatever reason,
the decision was made that I wouldn't.
Okay.
So you don't go back in and,
but you're our back active duty and now you'd think that Jodie was all super
squared away now,
but you are or you,
well it was a,
it was a rough transition Jocko and uh,
yeah,
that,
that came after
your active duty,
right?
Well,
yeah,
I'm a full time private.
I was a corporal in the reserves.
Right.
Busted back down to private show up.
There's a lot of politics going on,
uh,
right now and at time because the regular army is being told that has to take
reserves.
Whereas before it was like,
if you need them,
you can take them.
Now it's even if you don't need them,
you're going to take 30% so you have a battalion of infantry guys,
let's say one RCR at full strength is usually a,
at this time it was about 700
cut,
30% off of active duty are good to go guys.
And now they're put aside and 30% reserve show up to take their spot.
Ouch.
Yeah,
so that,
and this was mandated by our headquarters.
And so the politics within the unit was,
can I,
we're allowed to swear on this,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
the reg force guys were all like,
fuck you and the horse,
she came in on and,
and that horse is mom and anybody else associated with that horse.
I show up.
They thought because I was at,
they thought I was a reserve because the RCR has a reserve battalion.
So they,
they thought I was a reserve RCR.
Right.
And then when they found out I was a direct entry,
which means I go directly from the reserves into the reg force without going
through the RCR battle school.
Huh.
So they just gave you that cap badge w well,
yeah,
but I did basic training in the reserves two,
three years ago.
Oh Yo,
you did.
Huh?
And I got,
man,
it was rough.
It was rough.
But it,
and it got rougher cause you got in trouble.
Yeah.
So I don't know why,
by the way,
just so you know,
you wrote this in the book that's been published.
So acting like this didn't happen.
Now is a little bit through it.
You got arrested.
I did get arrested.
I don't trust anyone who hasn't at least been handcuffed.
That's a good point,
right.
I made a mistake.
So we were now,
well,
the preamble to this was that I did eventually get sent to the RCR battle school
and that's where I did get arrested.
Another one of the trainees and I,
uh,
well the,
the whole platoon went out.
Of course,
being young men,
we somehow found ourselves at a,
a gentleman's nightclub.
And,
uh,
we were enjoying our evening and one of the guys who decided he wanted to get
some cocaine and I was,
how old was I?
20.
I had never even seen the stuff except for in Miami Vice.
Um,
and I'm like,
what's the point?
We're already here.
We're having fun.
I'm already got a few drinks,
got some girls,
uh,
sitting with us.
Why,
why leave?
And he was adamant.
So I guess in his civilian life,
this was something he got got into.
And in my mind I was just like,
okay,
so he's gonna like leave on his own and go somewhere where you like in Miami
vice,
it's always like the worst part of town,
right?
Guess what?
It was the worst part of town.
So I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to go with you.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't need any,
but,
but I'll be there in case they try to Mug ya or jump you turns out he was buying
it from an undercover cop cars,
you know,
like,
who else are you gonna buy an off?
Right.
And then when,
after they bused us.
So we're like walking back to the club.
I'm like,
okay,
finally,
right.
I can get back and start hanging with the girls again.
Started getting my drink on.
We get tackled by guys bigger than you and I,
uh,
and,
and like,
they're,
so they're the under the NARC guys and they're like,
what do you do?
And you create,
they look at her id that you guys are in the,
in the army and you're going to smoke crack.
And I'm like,
what?
I look at the guy,
I'm like,
what's he talking about?
He's like,
well,
I might have,
they might not have had any coke,
so I might've bought.
And I'm like,
oh my gosh.
I'm just like,
but now that's the reality of my life.
Right.
And I can't,
there's no going back.
There's no changing it.
And it was,
it was at the time I described it as the worst year of my life,
but maybe it was the best,
the,
the subsequent year because it taught me a lot about myself.
Yeah.
And that's the main reason why I kind of wanted to tell that.
Wanted you to talk about that because number one,
like you said,
it's a mistake that you made that,
you know,
I've had that feeling too before,
where you're,
you're just like,
okay,
this is my reality now.
There's no,
you can't go backwards.
You're cuffed.
Yeah.
And yet you had,
you transitioned from it and in the book,
here's how you kind of talk about that transition,
because they're going to send you back to me for it.
What's it mean for me?
Fred was the battle school,
so they're going to send you to the battle school for another crack at it.
Your third crack at it.
My second crack at battle school,
but my third infantry course station.
Yeah.
So here's what you did.
And by the way,
you are teeter tottering this whole time.
They don't know if they're gonna kick you out.
They might let you in because just so everybody knows,
the cops even took your side and we'll,
you know,
they said,
hey,
this guy didn't have anything to do with it,
but it didn't matter.
The military
guilty by association.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the lunch,
the police department was like,
Jodie,
you clearly had nothing to do with it.
But yeah,
guilty by association.
Right.
And so they go back and forth,
find that you get orders.
Okay,
we're going to let you stay in.
And now you say this,
I had two choices.
I could be pissed off forever and feel hard done by,
or I could go back to Medford with a new attitude and make the best of it.
I could keep my head high and get off the bus with the shiniest boots,
the best pressed uniform,
the best laid out kit,
and the best attitude and be in the best shape of anybody there.
Okay?
And that's what you did.
So what I did,
so anybody that's out there that's listening to this podcast that hit a little
bump in the road,
that's what you do.
You show up with the best attitude,
the best shape
with your head held high and you get after it.
Extreme ownership.
You've got to own it.
Yeah,
no hiding from it.
There's no explaining way out of it.
There's No side,
no sideways maneuver you're going to make.
You're that guy.
I was that guy.
Oh there's that guy.
Yeah.
So now fast forwarding a little bit,
uh,
you deploy now,
you're now you're legit part of the regiment.
Yup.
Finally,
and you deployed to Kosovo,
which at the time was a real world mission.
I'm sure you were fired up.
I know I would've been fired.
I didn't go to Kosovo,
but I would've been fired up to go to Kosovo because it was the only game in
town.
I still remember when our,
see when our commanding officer said we got,
we gathered up in the parade hall and he said one our is going to Kosovo.
And I still remember I was saying,
you know,
we're,
you know how at ease he got your hand behind your back.
Right.
My hand went into a fifth and I had to stop myself from doing,
I fist bump us.
You are going to become James Bond,
Chuck Norris and Rambo all.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's going to be glorious.
So you go to coast Samoan and you know what?
We're kind of joking about it,
but it was a legit mission at the time.
There was,
there was stuff that was happening there.
I like this little section here.
You got,
you're talking about the Russians cause you're stationed near some Russian folks
and you said this,
we like to think we're tough as as Canadians,
but it turned out this Russian unit where we're Russian airborne,
who'd come from the fighting and Chechnya and we've gone into some pretty,
you did.
I just talked about checking and we talk about GSD in here.
These guys took things to a whole new level.
They were hardcore soldiers.
We would complain when our showers weren't giving us warm water.
Then we'd look over to the Russian camp and see soldiers outside in minus 25
degrees washing themselves with snow or out in tee shirts,
cutting firewood.
These guys were sleeping in world war two Eric tense while we were sweating
inside our heated barracks and every morning they'd be outside in the ball
freezing cold running,
doing chin ups and bench pressing big truck tires.
These guys were legit.
Yeah.
We didn't know there is some,
there was some stuff going on at the Pristina airport at that time.
That's why they were there.
Do you remember,
do you remember this situation at all?
Briefly.
So NATO did it's bombing thing,
right?
Bomb the Serbians out of Kosovo basically.
And then it was like,
okay,
so when NATO stabilization forest k for the Kosovo stabilize or whatever it was,
um,
was going to move in and you know,
everyone was going to get a sector British,
Russian or British,
Canadian French,
blah,
blah blah.
Right.
As we're like loading up on our vehicles,
that brigade or I don't know how many big ways of Russians just basically showed
up in the middle of the night at the Pristina airport,
which was also a military airport.
And they set up a perimeter around this like mountain bunker in there,
which just recently I read an article about it and they were like,
yeah,
the,
hey guys,
it's been however it's been 20 years.
Uh,
this is what was in there.
Oh Shit.
It was full of stuff that shouldn't have been there.
So that's,
that's why everybody was like,
what are they doing here?
Why do they only want to be there?
Cause they were like,
yeah,
we're here to help guys.
Uh,
we're just going to be right here in this area.
Don't ever come in here or will or we'll kill ya but we'll be right here.
We're just here to help.
No big deal.
We want to,
we want to be part of the part of the exercise.
But they were there to guard this.
There's like bunker and there is like a lot of,
there was like,
I guess there was some nuclear biological weapons in there and,
and some migs that should never have been in that part of Europe apparently.
And in the middle of the night you'd hear planes taking off and nobody knew what
they were.
Uh,
but you know,
nothing really of substantial events happened in Kosovo.
You get home from that and this is when you get the opportunity to go to sniper
training,
which is outstanding.
And,
and I thought you did a great job here of pointing out what a sniper is.
Cause people have little ideas in their heads about what a sniper is and here's
Jody's version of what a sniper is.
A true snipers.
Someone who's willing to do pretty much anything to accomplish the mission.
The sniper has a particular mindset and shooting is actually one of the easier
parts of the role.
I've seen men at the rifle range who are amazing marksman,
but who would be terrible snipers because they don't have the patients.
They lack the ability to deny their own needs and to put the mission first.
A true sniper will make himself uncomfortable just to make the shot.
That is something so true.
The guys think that the,
that what a sniper is someone that shoots really well.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the least.
That's the easiest thing I can teach you.
Right.
If I need you to be a sniper,
that's the easiest thing I can get you to do.
You know that movie shooter with our Buddy Mark Walberg there?
I have not seen it.
It's based on a book about a Vietnam era as neighbors,
but anyway,
he,
he takes this like guy who just teams up with them for the movie and he makes
him the shooter.
Like the DI teachers.
We had a shoot because that's the easy part.
All that other stuff I I talk about.
Yeah,
that's the part I'm looking for.
That's what I'm looking for.
In a sniper,
you could shoot all day.
I could put you on the range and you could shoot bulls eyes from 900 meters all
day as long as you got your Gatorade,
as long as you get your 10 minute break,
as long as they'll let you get up and go pee pee.
But what have,
I don't let you do any of that stuff.
Then what?
Oh,
is it sunny out on let's too bad.
Yeah,
it's sunny out man.
It was it or is it going to rain?
Yup.
Don't get up.
Your target might come up,
but what if there's ants crawling?
You're inviting your eyes.
The eyes is problematic.
I would admit.
I would,
I would allow you to just scratch the answer to your eyes.
But,
but your target might come up while you're scratching.
Yeah,
I wouldn't get up if I was you.
The all the sniper courses.
Definitely.
You talk about in the book you talk about stalking and that's something that no
one,
I haven't seen that movie but no one really understands the difficulty in the
challenging and the self discipline.
It's an exercise in self,
self discipline to crawl,
you know,
one meter every 10 minutes.
It's hard to get to a position where you can see your target and take the shot
because you have to.
Yeah.
Because you have to have the patients too.
And the mindset to like,
I don't know if it made it into the book,
I can't,
I know you should know your own book,
but um,
I remember I was as leopard crawling with a guy and we were on,
it wasn't even a sniper thing,
it was just like a feel a like a,
like a field craft thing.
So we were learning how to just stop just as soldiers and we were,
we were side by side,
but he was literally on an elevation,
maybe four inches higher than me.
And I remember I was looking at him and I was like,
that's not a good spot to be.
Freeze.
Boom Walker came over,
got him.
I was,
I was in direct line of sight but I was just that four inches lower.
You got to like have the patients to look at the ground and go,
I'm going to go this way even though it's out of your way because you can't be
within sight of,
of the spotters are of the enemy.
And that guy went on to become our tier.
He joined our tier one unit.
He's a,
he's a JTF guy.
But I remember at that time it's so,
it's not like he was a dummy or anything and,
and I,
and we're right.
I learned a valuable lesson.
I learned a lesson.
But,
but that's the mindset I'm looking for from day one,
from a guy that I'm going to put through sniper school.
Cause we don't,
we don't have a lot of numbers in Canada.
You know,
like I was telling you at any given time there might be 150,
maybe 180 snipers active at any time.
And in the forces and that might,
and that,
you know,
if you add in our tier one,
tier two guys,
or maybe there's 200,
so I don't have time to,
to go looking for the best guys.
You know,
you have to come,
you basically got to come to come to us.
And uh,
and so I'm looking for the patients.
I'm looking for the guy who's going to take that extra five minutes and look at
the ground.
He's,
who's not going to,
when I tell him,
okay,
you can go,
go,
start stocking.
Who's going to sit there for another five,
10 minutes,
lose that time,
but study the root on his map,
you know,
cause it's easy to start run and then you go,
Oh man,
oh shit,
I should know where I'm going.
And no time spent on the map as time saved on the ground.
Right.
And you,
so you're looking for that guy and there's this just,
it's,
it's uh,
it's probably the same with seals.
You just,
you don't,
it's hard to describe,
but you know it when you see it.
So you get done with sniper school,
you spend some more time and then September 11th happens,
came on,
and the opportunity comes up
for you to go on deployment.
Now,
you'd already been through sniper school,
you were a sniper,
but the opportunity,
there's no opportunity for a sniper deploy.
What they need is a driver.
Right?
Which drivers slash.
Security.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is,
I mean,
it's definitely a dangerous job.
It's definitely a monotonous job.
It's not,
it's not a glorious job by any stretch,
but,
and also what's rough about being a drivers,
you have a lot less control over your own fate.
I mean,
you're basically in a defensive situation when you're driving in a convoy,
you're in a defensive situation.
That's all there is to it.
So here you're a target,
you're a target,
you've been trained to be the hunter,
and now you get an offer to go on deployment to be the hunted.
Basic has a driver.
And of course,
because you're
a warrior,
you say,
Oh,
you need a driver.
You don't need a sniper,
but I'm going to go to Afghanistan.
All right,
bring it on.
Yeah,
that was it.
It was stay home or be a driver.
Pretty easy choice for [inaudible].
Pretty simple.
So now you were,
what were these little jeeps who driving Altis it's true.
What do you guys got that's comparable?
Nothing.
Um,
does it just like a little Land Rover type vehicle?
Yeah.
But it's like,
not even like it's,
it's a,
it's almost a class of its own is armored.
No,
no,
it's like a little,
um,
Dune buggy looking thing.
It had like a four cylinder engine built originally by Volkswagen.
Um,
we,
they were roughly the same look as it original willys jeep.
But that's where the similarities end.
And you get to Afghanistan and your,
your driveway or where are you?
Where were you?
Cool.
That was cool.
And so you're driving people around the city?
Yeah.
From base to wherever they got to go from the airport to our main base,
which was,
um,
what was the name of that camp again?
Sorry,
I forget the main camp we had in Afghanistan,
but it was between the king and Queen's Palace.
Got It.
And uh,
yeah,
they'd go there or because it was,
um,
officers and liaison officer's mostly that we worked with.
Right.
So it'd be like go liaison with the Turkish guys,
go liaison with the Germans,
go liaison with this Afghan warlord dinner somewhere.
You'd sit around,
wait,
yeah,
yeah.
Basically.
And we'd be as body guards when he was there and stuff.
Like we said,
there's a threat.
You obviously you were prepared for anything of course,
but you,
you know,
there wasn't a super high threat.
Right.
However,
there's always a threat,
and I'm going to the book here.
The oldest jeeps were not designed to withstand and attack.
This fact became a starkly apparent when three,
three RCR guys were driving to illness and hit a mine to them.
Sergeant Robert Short and Corporal Rob Bearden finger died immediately and the
driver,
Tj Sterling,
a friend of mine survived though he was injured after the incident,
Tj was brought to the hospital at Camp Warehouse and meet another one of the
guys from the regimen went to see him.
This was the first time I'd seen one of our guys hit by a land mine.
In fact,
it was the first time I'd seen a casualty at all.
Okay.
Dj was pretty banged up.
A couple of his teeth were broken and he may have had a broken draw.
He had lacerations all over.
There's always a particular odor in the hospitals around people who have
suffered traumatic injuries.
I remember smelling that odor like blood or maybe just what I thought blood
smelled like.
Tj was on a stretcher with big wheels.
We'd use this kind of stretcher before in training.
Okay.
To me it was a kind of prop.
This thing we used for simulations.
Okay,
but this was not a simulation.
This was the real thing.
Tj was still in shock.
It had taken a few hours for him to be extracted from the scene of the
explosion.
Shorty and beer and finger are gone.
He said,
yeah man.
We replied.
We heard I need a smoke,
man.
I need a smoke.
Tj said,
okay.
But doctors and nurses wouldn't allow it,
but as soon as they were out of the vicinity,
we lit a cigarette for Tj and gave him a couple of drags.
Ah,
that's way better.
Thanks.
We stayed and chatted with TJ about some inconsequential things,
trying to keep a fellow royal in a good state of mind.
For me personally,
I was learning from what was happening facing the reality that when things go
wrong,
you have to get that smell in your nostrils and look those sites right in the
eye.
Sadly,
a few years later,
TJ ended up taking his own life.
I was a pallbearer at his funeral and as I carried his coffin,
I wondered if he carried guilt for being the lone survivor in that incident.
Yeah,
so really to me that's like you're welcomed to war.
and
when you talked about getting that smell in your nostrils and look in those
sites right in the eyes,
that's I think an important thing for people to remember.
Yeah.
You don't,
when things are bad,
some people want to deny that it's happening.
They want to hold their nose and shield their eyes from it.
Wrong answer.
Breathe
it in.
Yeah,
and our Gig,
especially breathe it in.
You have to,
that you have in our line of work,
that's the norm.
And I'll tell you,
I have been working with,
worked with a bunch of different companies and bunch of different industries.
They run into these situations too.
You know where their company's going to fail or they're,
if there's a problem there,
there's things go wrong and no,
you don't want lives are not at stake.
And I say this all the time,
but livelihoods are,
and if you're the CEO of a company,
you're going to have to now lay off 500 people,
a thousand people,
three people,
and now that person is not going be able to afford their mortgage or pay for
their kids or get food on the table.
That is serious business.
You're ruining someone's life.
If you want to shield your eyes at that moment had,
you'd want to hold your nose so you don't have to smell it.
You're wrong.
Yeah.
And obviously this to here for Tj.
Okay.
This is,
you know,
we're talking about the psychological wounds.
Yep.
People get,
yeah.
Which for him were worse than his physical wounds.
He,
I remember one time after I got hit,
um,
because he,
he,
he actually came back with us in an o six on the tour I was wounded on and he
stayed in the talk the whole time.
But,
um,
I remember we were back and I,
you know,
I was hit and we were at his house and we're having a little bit of a party and
he,
he was crying because he couldn't believe that he,
cause he got,
he was wounded and he got a monthly stipend for,
for his injuries.
And he was still at,
but he was still active duty and stuff.
And,
and,
and I,
when I wounded,
we had a new veterans system come in where I just got like a lump sum payment
and he was crying about how cow is it that he can get this money,
but I only get this money.
And Jody,
what happened to you is so much worse than what happened to me.
And I was,
why are you worried about I'm,
I'm okay man,
I'm alive.
We're here,
we're having some drinks.
Okay.
But he was so tore up inside about what happened to me versus what happened to
him over what happened to shorty and baron finger.
And,
uh,
he,
he just carried that and I've,
and,
and you hear about that survivor's guilt thing.
Yeah.
And you don't realize how real it is till you see it.
And even after I got wounded,
when I came home,
I felt like shit because my boys are still back there.
And then when they went back in 2010 because our unit rotated back into theater,
it killed me.
I was dying inside.
That's my,
those are my guys,
you know,
they're over there without me and I'm letting them down because I was,
I told him I was going back with them.
I said,
don't worry guys,
I'll get better.
I'll go back.
And I had to like really come to grips with that.
And you know,
Tj could,
you know,
we,
we lose too many guys that's to that stuff.
But I've,
oh,
I don't know.
I never had those thoughts.
I never thought of of ending my own life ever.
But,
um,
I've known enough guys that have done it that clearly it becomes an option to
some people and I'm,
I'm at the point with it.
Cause it,
it just happened,
uh,
maybe a month ago with a,
with a guy I worked within the Green Berets and,
uh,
okay.
I just don't think we can save them all.
I don't know if we're going a year ago.
I mean,
I think I texted you when it happened.
Right.
And tweeted at you did,
he texted me and,
and that one really,
my wife,
Atlanta,
she's never seen me cry.
And I cried that night for Johnny and,
and it was because we,
we thought we had him,
he was living at one of the guy's house that was on the team that we w we worked
with,
you know,
uh,
he had a girlfriend and like things were looking good.
And,
uh,
you know,
I've,
I've had to come to the conclusion in my own mind that
we're not getting,
we're not going to save them all.
And this is a side effect of the Gig of the life.
We chose that some of our comrades are going to go that direction.
And if you,
if I was to dwell on it the way Tj did,
then I would become like Tj and I can't afford to do that.
You know,
use the word dwell.
And that's a,
that's a word that I use as well.
I use the word dwell and I,
and I,
and I always say
that you got to face these things.
Yeah,
you got to understand these things.
You got to actually embrace these things.
You got to bring them in,
but you can't dwell on them.
That's right.
And I think that's the key is to,
is honestly to do what you,
what you said is to breathe it in,
to look it in the,
I deal with it,
but don't dwell on it.
Move on.
Stay there.
That's right.
Move on.
Accept it as a consequence of the actions you've chosen and move on to the next
step.
Otherwise you'll be that guy talking about that high school football pass that
you,
that you caught and it,
I know it's an analogy that fits here because we talked about this in your car.
There's some guys,
I was a sniper,
I was a navy seal,
I was a paratrooper,
I was a machine gunner,
whatever it is.
I was a Jiu Jitsu black belt,
you know,
whatever it is,
and that's where they're stuck.
That's where their dwelling there in purgatory,
in that whatever ring of Hell you want to call it stuck in that moment and
you've got to move on.
You can't dwell because that's where you're getting,
you're going to die when you dwell
it real simply.
What you gotta do is you got to just take a step,
got to take that step forward.
You gotta,
you gotta look,
you gotta look at it in the eyes,
then you got to walk away and you got to walk forward.
Then move forward and make something,
make go in another direction.
Go forward.
Don't go backwards.
Yeah,
and it,
and the other part is,
except that maybe you can't change things.
Well,
you can't change what's happened in the past.
Yeah.
You cannot do that.
It happened.
And um,
you're not going to change it.
So what are you going to do?
Are you going to let it drag you down?
Are you going to dwell on it forever?
Don't,
don't do that,
man.
I know.
It gets a hold of you.
I know it's a tough one.
It can,
but deal with it.
Except that you can't change it except that you're here for a reason to do
something.
You have the opportunity that maybe your buddies didn't get,
they didn't get.
Nevermind.
Maybe you have an opportunity that your buddies did not get.
You think they would want to have you kill yourself.
No.
They'd want you to live and that's what you need to do.
Yeah.
Honor them.
By living an awesome life every day.
Make the change be the difference.
You know,
you can't change the world,
but you could change.
You could change somebody else's day.
You can be the positive influence in your little tiny sphere.
You're my,
my influence in the world.
Yours echoes.
It's not the world.
But it makes someone else happy.
Yeah,
you can.
You can be the difference between a good day and a bad day for someone.
You know,
when I,
when I decided that I was going to try and become an officer in the seal teams,
part of that part of my decision,
what's cause I,
I'm like,
I was going to be an admiral or or whatever.
It's going to be like just,
and I said,
you know what?
Because I had a prior enlisted officer that was just made our lives awesome
because he was such a great guy and I said to myself,
you know what,
I might not change the world but I'm going to have a Kool seal platoon one day
and those guys are going to,
those guys are going to be fired up and we're going to kick ass.
Just my little world.
Just that little thing.
And no matter where you are,
you got that little world.
Maybe like you said,
maybe it's one other person,
maybe it's just yourself,
but you make that little part of your world a little bit better.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you wake up in the morning.
I firmly believe you decide how that day is going to go.
Absolutely.
Whether,
you know,
I missed,
I missed my flight to come down.
I should have been here yesterday.
I missed my flight.
I own that.
I had a bad morning and I was,
I think I was even on the phone with you.
And I said,
yeah,
extreme ownership,
my fault.
And you and you giggled at me and you said,
Yup.
Uh,
own it,
whatever.
And then I,
uh,
my,
one assistant called me and I
said,
you know what?
I'm done being pissed off.
You know,
cause I can't,
I'm not going to let this one thing ruined the rest of my day and the rest of my
weekend.
How's that helping you move forward?
How is that helping the rest of your day?
How has that helped you get here right now?
It doesn't help anything.
That doesn't mean,
that doesn't mean be a robot either though.
No.
Do you deal with it?
Process it.
Don't,
don't get me wrong.
I was really mad yesterday morning.
Uh,
and it takes a lie waiting for you down here.
I had all kinds of goods.
I'm like,
I'm all the things to be laid for it.
Yeah,
that's right.
A guy like you want a guy like Jocko to think you're a shit.
You know you're plugging,
can't make a timing,
but
you know,
everything's gonna be okay.
I'm here,
we're still doing the podcast.
It's beautiful weather.
I got to see my kids.
I got to pick them up from school because I didn't think I was gonna.
I got to,
you know,
I got to see some friends walk the dogs that day and I,
and I,
I,
but I made that decision myself though.
I was sitting on my,
on the edge of the bed.
I didn't have my prosthetic legs on yet.
And I said,
okay,
you,
you're pissed off now you're done.
And I got up and I carried on with the day because okay,
it's easy to say.
It's easy for us to say,
take that step.
Don't dwell,
move on.
But I firmly believe if you decide you can change your circumstance,
that's a decision you have to make in your own mind.
I firmly believe it and it might not feel like it today,
but try again tomorrow and then try again the next day.
And you know what,
call me before you,
before you make any decisions,
just,
just please just call me first call.
Or if you're,
if you have jockos number,
call him.
Because the world is definitely better with you here than without you.
No doubt about it.
And I hate to keep hammering this nail,
but,
but it's just a theme that I'm tired.
I'm tired of hearing a buddy of mine,
another sniper had a heart attack.
Um,
not long after that.
That guy killed himself is great dude.
He's a legend in the Canadian sniper world and he was diabetic and he smoked a
thousand cigarettes a day and drank a million beers a week and they said the
heart attack was so fast.
He probably was because they found them in bed.
He was crawling into bed and probably and was dead before he's had even hit the
pillow.
That's how massive a heart attack it was.
When I heard it was a heart attack,
I was actually happy because I,
because when I heard it,
I went,
oh,
I just went.
I just went shooting with him.
He was in a great mood.
They're like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It was a heart attack.
And I went,
oh,
thank God that's,
that's,
that's the point I'm at with this,
with that subject.
So anyway,
let's move on man.
Let's talk about puppy dogs and rainbows.
Okay.
We're not there yet.
No,
not yet.
I always a good reference.
You know,
Miss my flight.
Good.
I can bring my kids to school and all these good things came out of it.
That's right.
So I would like to go rainbows,
but we're not there yet.
All right,
brother hit me.
So now you're,
you're coming back from Afghanistan and you know,
you've got your girlfriend and whatnot.
And
here we go.
My first tour in Afghanistan ended a few weeks later and I headed back home.
I was still haunted by all the things I had witnessed and kaboodle.
Images played over and over in my head,
whether it was small children begging for money,
a mother holding a dead baby in the streets,
or my buddy TJ bloodied up from a roadside bombing.
My girlfriend expected me to return as the same guy who had left six months
earlier when I was a different man.
Now a different Jody,
everything around me look different too.
Maybe things had changed much,
but I felt like I was on an alien planet.
My girlfriend had redecorated the house moving stuff with the furniture around
and repainting the bedroom and I found it upset me.
Life had gone on without me and that fact was hard to take.
People around me kept saying,
what's wrong with you,
Jody?
You've changed.
And that would make me even more upset.
Not because they were wrong,
but because I thought I was the kind of soldier who could just walk it off.
Okay.
But few soldiers can.
It takes time after a tour of duty for a soldier to readjust to civilian life.
And I wish I'd known that earlier.
I was expected to continue life just,
I lived it before my tour,
but I couldn't,
not right away.
I couldn't step back into my normal routine as if I hadn't witnessed anything on
mission.
I couldn't just hop in the car and go to the grocery shopping like everything
was fine.
It's interesting that you kind of felt like you were weak sauce cause you were
not the exact same before you went on deployment.
Yeah.
You feel like a pussy
even though you know you shouldn't feel like a pussy.
Right.
You feel like a pussy.
It,
it,
it's,
it's the most frustrating at the time.
It was one of the most frustrating things because you want to be that guy for,
for,
for your,
for your woman.
You of course,
I'm still that awesome Alpha male that you fell in love with and can you can,
you can whatever doesn't,
you know,
doesn't blink at anything except that water bottle at the side of the road.
Right.
There was that pallet garbage do it right there.
What do you mean?
I should just drive?
Oh right.
Yeah.
This is our street.
Sorry.
It's not a road in.
Cool.
Um,
and,
and uh,
yeah,
I just
w I,
like I said,
I wish I'd had advice that,
you know,
be prepared for the fact,
because when I went to Kosovo you like,
cause I've had the people ask me,
well you didn't have that reaction when you came back from Kosovo.
Well,
I lived in the barracks.
All my shit was in storage.
I didn't have a girlfriend.
I had a girl that I was dating.
She picked me up,
uh,
when we got home.
But like,
it's not like we were going to get engaged or anything.
And you know,
I didn't have any real belongings.
You know,
I've,
I,
you know,
I still lived at the unit.
This was a house I had bought a,
you know,
my girlfriend had moved in,
she was talking about kids and marriage and we had dog,
we had a dog.
And I came home and I was like,
what happened to my house and what is going on?
And like,
you know what I told my dad when I went to Kosovo,
um,
you know,
in the book I talk about my dad,
one of the three times I've seen him cry in my life was when I deployed to
Kosovo for the first time.
And,
and I said,
hey man,
don't worry about it.
Six months.
Hey,
what's six months?
Right?
It's like six haircuts.
It's six,
six mortgage payments.
It's nothing.
Don't worry about it.
And I come home and I couldn't even think that way myself.
And uh,
you know,
and I know I'm,
I don't know if you felt like that after your first deployment.
Um,
but this one was different because I guess there I had a life to come home to
besides,
besides the unit,
I've always been very compartmentalized in a way,
I think,
right?
Sometimes probably to a detriment to
my family a little bit.
But I've always been very careful with like a work come home.
I'm not a,
I'm not at work anymore,
so just stop thinking about that stuff.
And it's,
it's,
it's usually pretty positive.
But the problem is,
is that when you get to,
you realize you're compartmentalizing your family out of the picture,
kind of which I would have a tendency to do.
So.
And I mean that's probably part of one of the things that,
but even even when you were real young guy,
okay.
Like,
like how long have you been married?
I've been married for a long time and I'm always been like that.
Okay.
I honestly,
it's wrong I think,
but the seal teams was always the biggest priority in my life.
And you know,
people will be like,
oh,
family first.
That was not true for me.
And luckily my wife understood that and she didn't hold it against me.
Right.
She knew that someday she knew the seal teams.
It wasn't gonna last forever.
And all you guys in the military,
I'll tell you what,
the military does not last forever.
Well,
the big green machine rolls on.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and,
and the people that are there when you're,
when you fall off,
those are the ones you got to worry about when you're still on.
Yup.
And so that's why I think I just was able to compartmentalize what you know
away.
Right.
And I would basically be almost a schizophrenia of this is the guy that works
and this is the guy that's at home,
he's dad or whatever.
And boom.
I just had that really good split and I think it was beneficial to me.
Probably it was probably is.
Yeah.
Nice.
I guess I assumed I was that guy too,
because that's what I,
you know,
I approached most things that way,
but maybe just having that little home of my own for that one tour and then
also,
you know,
losing a couple buddies for the first time.
Maybe.
I Dunno,
I dunno what the thing,
it's not like it,
it didn't wreck anything.
Like my career was fine.
Like it was just,
well,
I mean I lost a fiance out of it,
but
yeah.
Yeah.
And that's what happens next.
So she announced,
this is back to the book here.
She announced that she was leaving.
I was shocked because I didn't want to break things off.
I just wanted to postpone the wedding.
But for her,
this was all too much.
Our relationship was over while I was certain this was the right time to get
well,
I wasn't certain this was the right time to get married.
I was certain about one thing.
I wanted to go back to Afghanistan and this time as a sniper.
And that's something that,
yeah,
I mean that's something that it's hard to reconcile the feeling of just wanting
to go back.
I mean,
that's
that one.
I want to go back right now.
Yeah,
of course.
People,
Hey,
what's it like?
You asked me what's it like to be in politics?
I go,
I'd rather be killing Isis,
uh,
frankly.
And I,
you know,
I'm not ashamed to say it.
I was good at it.
And,
and,
and I love the people that are out there doing it for us.
You know,
even though I'm not one of them anymore.
You know what,
w w we,
we kind of skipped over,
but nine 11 happened during my sniper course.
And sniper courses.
We don't just have a rotation.
I'm going on in Canada.
We're very small military.
If you're on a sniper course,
holy shit like you,
you've got,
you got there,
they run like one or two a year or something.
Maybe there's not even every year while there now I think it is,
but back then mine was the first one in three years that had happened.
25 of us tried out,
three of us passed.
So it's not like you get on it and it's okay,
just got to pass.
So,
but nine 11 happened on like day five or six or something.
And you know,
as the towers fell,
we watched it fall on TV.
Like they interrupted a class,
we thought it was like a Cessna,
right?
The guy comes up,
someone just flew a plane into the World Trade Center,
we're and we're in the middle of a,
you don't interrupt a class,
you know?
Right.
You don't interrupt a training session.
We're like okay man,
thanks.
And the duty sergeant runs off,
but we think a drunk guy in a Cessna and then he comes back and then so we go
down to watch at the duty station and as it,
as the towers are falling.
I'm hearing like the starting bell,
right.
I'm hearing like the horn at the start of the Superbowl and I'm like,
oh it's on,
cause I was considering retiring because of the lack of action.
So you did get your,
I hate to call it a dream,
but you got your dream like I'm angry Afghanistan and this time,
this time you're going as a sniper.
Yeah.
Which is awesome.
You're back in Afghanistan and there's some heavy fighting going on now.
There's some legit fighting and and
the Canadians are actually leading operations,
which is the first time it quite some time I think since Korea.
Yeah.
Well this,
this what,
what we will re this was the first time we'd let operations that were non
peacekeeping ever since Korea.
Yeah,
you're right.
And this,
but we,
when we walked into was the first offensive in NATO's history
ever think about it.
Right.
NATO has never been on the offensive except for in Afghanistan.
Kind of weird but North Atlantic Treaty Organization.
But anyway,
this one was called operation but Dusa
this Canadian led op NATO operation was going to be different from anything we'd
done so far.
It was a bit of a wake up call.
So was the fact that my Buddy Jeff Walsh had been killed in friendly fire in an
accident that happened in August.
Clearly we were entering a high risk situation.
That didn't deter me in any way,
in any way.
If anything,
it made my resolve stronger.
I trained for this and I was ready.
Yeah.
It's a good feeling.
What,
uh,
what was the friendly fire?
Was the aircraft or was it shooting?
No,
this one was unfortunately,
uh,
it was his buddy in the vehicle.
They were sitting next to each other and,
okay.
Wow.
I guess he got in with his rifle not paying attention to the muzzle and it went
off and shot Jeff through the face and killed him.
That no one really knows exactly what happened,
but that's basically pretty much what everyone figures happened.
Muzzle discipline.
Mm.
Never point your weapon.
It's something you do not want to destroy.
Yeah.
And keep your finger off the trigger.
Keep your weapon on safe.
All right.
Now as you guys are getting ready to go into this operation,
but do so,
uh,
one of the orders that comes out is if anybody gets hurt during this mission,
we're going to stop right away and take care of it and you're going to make sure
the casualties are dealt with and then reassess the situation before moving
forward.
That was during the,
uh,
the company commander's orders,
right?
And you were kind of thinking,
wait a second.
Yeah.
For those
of you that don't know,
which is I'm sure people that aren't in the military,
when you're going on in attack your,
your ideas to maintain the momentum of the attack and you take casualties along
the way while you're attacking,
you keep attacking.
Yeah,
don't stop.
You know,
you're going to take casualties.
You're going to do,
people are going to get hit.
Things are going to slow you down.
You don't slow down.
You try and keep pushing forward.
You keep pushing forward.
Eve,
I've said it on this podcast before.
Aggression will mitigate risk.
So you get aggressive,
you move to the target,
you get the target secure,
then you can deal with the guys that are down.
Yeah.
Not that you're going to ignore them and you can't drop off a medic here and
there to,
to handle a situation,
but you're not going to stop.
I mean,
literally,
you know,
stop.
No,
you can't stop the whole battle group.
You can't split it.
You know,
the,
I don't know if the order was delivered the way it was intended,
but that's how it,
that's basically what,
that's to paraphrase what was said and that's why,
you know,
a couple of us were just kinda like,
yeah.
And what's really,
what's really,
uh,
to your point of,
you're not sure if that's what was meant.
What's really important is that the main thing you want to get across to your
troopers when you're going onto a soul is you want to the main point to be get
aggressive.
That's the main point that you want to get across to them.
Not,
hey,
the main points you're going to take away from this is if we take casually stop.
No,
we're going to get aggressive.
We're going to finish through the target.
We're going to secure the target and nothing's gonna stop us from doing that.
I don't care what happens.
That's what you want to have going into that.
That's my,
that was always my impression.
I've never been a company commander though.
But you've received plenty of orders.
Yes sir.
All right.
Now
we're starting to on the assault.
The assault is going down and here we go.
Up Ahead.
The first vehicles we're closing in on the white schoolhouse,
the Zettel mired cleared away for the lead platoon comprising of four lat la ves
and the g wagon to take position next to the school house.
It was at this point that the Taliban decided to make their presence known by
firing an anti tank recoilless rifle round at the softest vehicle of this lead
platoon,
the g wagon,
the round went right through the front windshield causing immediate casualties.
Next,
our whole soul opened up all at once.
Every cancer and every coaxial machine gun was firing.
Taliban were coming out of the weeds all around us,
out of tunnels,
windows,
mouse holes.
They had their head in the,
they had to held their powder to the last second and then it was game on.
They had the defenders advantage and they used it.
The call went out on the radio that one of our vehicles was hit and we had
casualties.
As this was happening,
one of the [inaudible] that was stuck next to the school house went nose first
into a ditch and was stuck.
I was trying to listen to on the radio when suddenly the troops who were
sticking out of the top patches of our lav yelled,
holy fuck,
they're right there.
They let go,
burst for their see sevens fallback grenade from a rifle mounted grenade
launcher.
At that moment,
our artillery began raining down and air support started dropping bombs on the
Taliban.
I felt helpless during all this chaos because the plan for us as snipers was to
get involved only once objective rugby had been achieved.
At that point we would get up on the school's roof and provide cover for the
bounce of the next objective.
But in this situation,
Barry cash.
So those are,
you're a sniper teammates bury cash.
And I were stuck inside the Lav right at the time when our shooting skills were
needed up top needed most up top.
I was working the radio,
doing my best to keep everyone in the vehicle informed of what was happening up
ahead.
Okay.
We've got three wounded in action and one killed in action.
I said relaying the message that there were three wounded soldiers and one who
was killed in the g wagon that had been hit.
Every soldier had his zap number,
which would be used as an identifier in case you were wounded or killed in the
field.
Standard operating procedure was that if someone died in combat,
you never revealed their name during the battle.
At this point,
we didn't know which soldier had been killed in that attack on the g wagon and
no one seemed to know the zap number either.
Finally,
the major got on the radio.
I need to know now who the fuck just got killed.
The radio crackled and a voice came on.
It was Warren officer,
Rick Nolan,
Sir
Rick Nolan was the soldier.
I had had a brief argument with the day before.
I've always felt bad that our last conversation was a little strained.
Rick was a good man and a great soldier sitting in the front seat of that g
wagon.
He had no chance of surviving a direct rocket hit.
I looked at Barry and cash.
We were all stunned into silence.
No matter how much do you prepare for that moment when a soldier,
you know,
becomes a casualty,
there's nothing that compares to the actual feeling on top of that.
It was jarring for all of us because we just didn't expect a soldier with his
level of experience and status to be the first one taken out on the mission.
That section right there
reminding me we were,
I had guys out.
Mm.
Um,
they were clearing the sector of Ramadi and big gun fight broke out.
And um,
I dunno,
three or 400 meters away,
maybe 500 meters away,
whatever it was,
I can just hear gunfire,
mayhem,
radios.
I got up to a rooftop and um,
um,
know,
hey,
what's up?
And I hear the,
the element commander got on the radio and he said,
hey,
we're did he casualty evacuation?
We've got one killed in one mood
and
they were with,
I don't know,
probably 20 Iraqi soldiers and five or six seals,
but you don't know who it is,
right?
It's on waiting.
Right?
You don't want to say anything on the radio.
And I'm waiting and I,
and finally I just said,
is it Iraqi or American?
It was like the longest pause I've ever heard in my life.
And he comes back and he says both Iraqi and it was like,
they know folks,
the Iraqi,
but uh,
to the Iraqi soldiers.
But you know,
I was relieved,
very relieved at that point.
And you talk about that too and hear how somebody gets hurt or somebody gets
wounded or somebody gets killed and you,
you know,
it's one of your guys that you feel guilty when you hear the name and it's not
whatever one of your,
what are your bet better friends or whatever.
And that's uh,
one of those strange and freaking horrible things about war.
Yeah.
You guys were
okay.
I mean,
this was like a shit sandwich out of the gate.
Yeah,
you got gotta.
Remember this is the first time Canada has been on the offensive since Korea and
does it matter how much you train?
Uh,
the first few minutes are going to be sloppy until you get your shit together.
Well,
I shouldn't have even said Shit Sandwich.
I should've said this is combat.
That's it.
Because I mean,
it's going,
you go into there or you're setting up your positions,
you're moving into position.
The enemy hadn't really revealed himself as you said in the book.
They held their powder.
Yeah.
Well we,
we wondered if they were there at all because the day before we watched,
as they all drove out of the area,
fighting aged guys just drove away in trucks,
trucks full.
They left some guys behind.
They actually,
you know,
the average Taliban guy,
you don't even have to duck,
have you shooting at,
you're really,
I mean you should duck,
but the point is he's probably not going to hit you,
but they,
whoever they left behind,
we're guys that knew what the would knew,
what they were,
knew what they were doing.
And uh,
and I give them credit for that.
Like,
you know,
they're not soldiers as we consider it,
but they're,
they're tough guys.
You know,
and you guys,
you sniper team,
you guys didn't even have your body on it.
Yeah.
Well cause cause snake,
it's part of the,
you know,
what's the three rules of special ops rate.
Always look cool.
Always know where you are and if you don't know where you are,
make sure you look cool.
Right?
So wearing ball cabs and not having body armor makes you look cool.
But also in our minds and we trained,
we have enough shit to,
to Hump,
you know,
why add body armor to it and,
and helmets,
you know,
we're going to be in a position we shouldn't,
if we're being engaged,
we fucked up.
But I tell Ya,
we,
I don't know if you're gonna read it,
but there's a,
there's a few moment,
few minutes later I'm like,
I really wish I had some body armor and helmet on right now.
I'm not going to read it,
but that's why I brought it up and I was actually,
I was actually not going to bring it up,
but then I circled to bring it up.
You know why?
Because there's somebody out there that's in the field right now that's going on
some operation and they're thinking,
you know what,
I'd probably be better off if I didn't bring my body armor and I'm going to tell
you bring your body armor.
Yeah.
Bring your body armor.
I did one the operation that for a bunch of reasons,
I decided that I didn't need body armor.
Right.
And of course ended up in a bad scenario.
And the only thing I'm thinking as I have,
uh,
as I have a gun pointed at my chest is,
you're an idiot and you don't have body armor on.
We had,
um,
we had the strike plate in front of her chest rig,
but we found out after if we'd ever been struck in that plate,
it,
the spoil from the plate would have killed us because it's designed to be inside
the body armor.
Right.
The,
the Kevlar because it had a kevlar wrap around it,
around the,
around the ceramic.
But turns out it's not that rap.
Is there more just for aesthetics or something?
I Dunno.
But anyway,
so it's like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It has to be inside the issued vest in order for it to work a pocket in your,
in your chest rig.
Yeah,
I know.
That's not the other crazy thing.
Again,
for guys that are overseas right now,
even if you think you're going to be far enough away from a firefight,
if you get hit with an IED,
you want your body armor on.
I mean that's all
do it 100%.
I always wear my body armor and a vehicle.
Yeah.
After this.
But um,
but even the night I was hit,
I didn't have body armor on.
I Dunno.
I was just a weird thing for me,
but,
but I,
you know,
like the Romans and the Greeks,
the Romans,
they called it,
you know,
the first time you see combat,
seeing the elephant.
So,
you know,
we,
so let's go back to Rick.
So Rick,
he's a warrant officer.
So do you guys,
uh,
maybe a petty officer and chief petty officer,
roughly.
He's like a company.
He was the company quartermaster so he's not sergeant major,
but he's like the next NCO down.
I'm going to guess he had about 18,
20 years.
He would,
he had been a recon guy,
most of it,
you know,
I trained under him,
a mentor to under him.
You know,
it's like when you,
when you imagine casualties,
you're imagining private Smith and Corporal Jones and whoever.
But our first guy killed is a guy trained his whole life for war and he's the
first guy gone.
You know,
they,
there's no,
uh,
status.
There's no a seniority in combat.
No,
it doesn't care if you've trained every day for a hundred years or if you've
trained one day for ever.
And that bullet is that if it's got your name on,
it's got your name on it.
I was going to say good bullets.
Don't even have names on them.
They're going to hate you.
They're going to hit.
Yeah.
And that's why combat is.
So that's one of the things about combat that makes it so,
so damn awful is like you said,
you can train as hard as you can train,
you can make no mistakes.
You can be the perfect warrior on the perfect mission and you can still get
blown up.
You can still get shot and there's nothing you can do about it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I hate to say it.
There's nothing you can do about it.
You're getting in,
you're going to be trained and led with other people and that bullet can hit
you.
Yeah.
And even if there are,
if they are dirt farmers with,
with 30 Year Old Aka,
if it's functioning,
it's a threat.
And you know,
I,
I've had chats with guys about why was,
why was that vehicle even on the objective when you had these perfectly good
armored vehicles.
Now these are up armored jeeps.
The,
these,
the GYG it's,
they're there.
They're the German one,
right?
Yep.
We'd only trained to this point.
Right.
And,
and,
and in training that vehicle went to the objective.
So why wouldn't it,
you know,
until,
until someone puts a recoilless rifle round through it and you go,
might be best to leave that one behind and maybe just get another lab for the,
for the company.
Quartermaster which after that they did.
But you know,
some lessons have been learned.
So the mayhem continues.
You end up helping collect the casualties.
Yeah.
And now you're sitting there,
you're at the,
what we would call a casualty collection point.
Do you use that term?
We'd call it,
they call it,
I don't know if you use that in here.
CCP.
So you,
okay.
So you're at the CCP casualty collection point and here you go.
One of the most important things in the field of battle is taken care of.
You're dead.
In fact,
the creed of the royals is never leave a royal behind on the field.
You want to get the bodies out of sight as quickly as possible.
It's demoralizing for a soldier to witness a dead comrade during battle,
especially when it's someone of Rick Stature.
I went into the back of an LAV,
grabbed a couple of body bags and got to work with some of our other guys.
We picked up Rick and zipped him into a bag.
One of the other fallen officers was frank mellish for a second.
I had a bit of hope because he was on a stretcher,
which meant he might have only been wounded,
but once I saw soldiers approach and check his dog tags,
I,
he was gone.
A casualty of the round that took out the Zettel Meyer.
Yeah.
The sad twist was that frank meloche and Rick Nolan had been friends for their
whole careers and now they were lying on the ground together.
Okay.
Next I helped put private William Kush Lee into a bag.
I'll never forget looking directly in to is still open eyes and saying,
sorry bro.
Okay.
As I zipped up his body bag
now that's obviously enough to crush
some people
mentally and emotionally at that point,
but
soldiers
don't have time.
Yeah.
Hey,
they have to do their jobs.
I mean,
what
as you went through that emotion
and then you turn around and you go,
okay,
what's next?
Yup.
How's that work?
Did you do
if I had spent more than that one second scene,
sorry Bro,
what am I missing?
I was doing,
I couldn't get my snipers into a position to be useful being snipers.
So we were being useful in other ways and once that problem was dealt with,
because you could,
you could see the guy like,
you know,
we were trying to reorganize ourselves here that we were in the reorg phase.
Right.
You know,
the guys are going the long way around of the vehicle because if they were lined
up next to the vehicle and so me and me and a couple of guys are like,
okay,
we got to fix this.
We fixed it.
And people you can,
if you felt you felt people relax.
And then my,
my main concern was that's still our objective and we got to get to it.
So what's next?
And that's when I went looking for,
I'm not even sure who's in charge at this point because we had taken so much of
our leadership had been hurt.
The company sergeant major,
two of the warrants,
uh,
you know,
and we had,
when that Zettel Meyer got hit,
um,
you know,
it,
it wounded a bunch of guys and you know,
we had Afghans with us,
we had some Americans with us.
Um,
uh,
what do you call the national guard?
I think there were National Guard,
uh,
mentors for the Afghans are with us.
Yep.
And,
um,
my biggest disappointment from that day,
and I know I'm going to catch some,
I might catch some shit from some guys that were there.
Yeah.
We didn't take our objective to this day.
Okay.
2016,
you know,
this is 10 years later,
almost in September,
it'll be 10 years.
And to this day I'm like,
fuck,
we didn't take her.
We didn't take or objective.
Yeah.
A part of that,
you know,
and,
and for one thing,
when I,
when I was reading that in,
I mean obviously it's just emotional moment and I knew that you just had to
detach from the emotion.
I use that term all the time.
Yeah.
You got to just detach from it and you gotta be conscious of that.
So like folks that are listening that are thinking,
how do you do that?
That's how you do it.
You cannot,
you got,
when you feel the emotions starting to override your logic and your ability to
do your duty,
that's what you have to do.
You have to go,
okay,
I've got to detach from those emotions and I've got to do my job now.
Yeah.
In that moment,
like I actually don't remember,
like I didn't really have any feelings.
You know,
I get more feeling now out of it.
Listening to you read it.
Yep.
Cause that
starting with,
especially when Tj got,
got hurt,
you know,
that's our workspace.
Yep.
Like you know,
here we're in an office.
You can see people typing doors,
opening,
closing.
That's the normal sound and vibe of this workspace.
We had burning vehicles,
we had dead dead soldiers,
we had wounded soldiers.
We had about 15 wounded by this point.
Um,
we had air support reining in,
we had artillery support,
reining in.
We had enemy mortars coming down.
And you know,
that's the norm.
The day don't like when you sign up to be a navy seal.
They don't hide the fact that you might get in gunfights.
It's like the first thing you read,
it's in big bold black letters you're going to,
you could get killed.
It's not in the small print at the bottom of the contract,
you know,
clause B of section four.
It's right there.
That's what you signed up for.
So,
okay,
it's not abnormal for these things to be happening,
which you have to do is accept that they happened and carry on with the job.
And in that moment,
I remember I said,
sorry Bro,
because I was,
it was almost,
I was on,
I was actually probably felt more like,
hey man,
sorry,
you're out of the game because it's going to get exciting from here.
You know,
I,
I was a fallen soldier in combat to me is,
especially at volunteer,
we weren't drafted.
Did anyone make you join the navy?
No.
I,
I fought with my parents to get into the army.
Yup.
I,
I would've,
I would've fist I would've fought 10 of my best friends.
They get that job as that sniper team leader and there was nowhere else I wanted
to be.
And if soldier falling in combat doing the job,
he chose in a plus,
it's not of our choosing.
Don't ever feel
sorry for me because I went to Afghanistan,
believe me,
I wanted to be there and for him to fall.
Okay.
I get in a lot of shit by some people,
but that's,
it's one of the greatest things a soldier can do is the fall for it with his
friends doing the job that,
that he chose or she chose and uh,
it's,
I,
I get in shit sometimes because I think like this,
well,
it's,
I think the reason that is,
is because it's so hard for people that don't know what that Brotherhood is
like.
They don't know what it's like to want to do that.
They don't understand that that's,
that's the soldier in the child.
That's the way you've wanted to be your whole life.
That's the way I wanted to be my whole life.
So to,
for these things to happen is,
is
it's like feeling bad for an MMA fighter cause they got punched in the face.
Yeah.
There you go.
Up for it.
You signed up for it.
It knows guys,
you know,
they,
they're there to fight and the military you're there to fight.
Yeah.
And a byproduct of fighting in this situation can be injury.
It can be death.
And like you said,
it's what we all signed up for.
And you know,
going back to the situation here,
one of the things that you talked about,
the fact that you guys didn't secure your objective and one of the reasons that
you didn't secure your objective the next day is because you had another
friendly fire incident.
Yeah.
And this is awful.
And,
and you know,
the book that I wrote a with Lafe starts off with,
with,
with the front of the fire scenario happening.
And I wish I could explain to civilians.
It's really hard for people to understand how these things happen.
I mean we've already talked about it.
What,
two times in this book,
here's another one.
Uh,
[inaudible] come in,
you're your beer basically like half awake,
trying to get,
trying to get a little bit of sleep.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden,
you know,
you hear the gunfire,
you hear things happening.
All of a sudden you hear an eight,
10 bursts go and cash your,
your,
your teammate cash.
He's like,
you're not going to believe this.
But I think he just strafed our own guys.
Strafed is when you fire machine gun canons,
weapon fires from an aircraft.
And sure enough,
30 soldiers,
more than 30 soldiers were injured.
Yeah.
And one was killed.
And by the way,
the one that was killed was private.
Mark Graham,
who was a Olympic spreader for Canada in 1992 in Barcelona.
Yeah.
I mean it's a nightmare.
It was a nightmare.
It was,
it was such a,
I even got mad at cash at first cause I was like,
because I heard it and you know that Brat that it's actually a nice feeling
until that happens.
And that one sounded weird cause like I was half a week and we,
and,
and I,
you know,
they were doing strafing runs across,
cause we were on each,
on each side of the Argan Dob River.
So,
you know,
there's a bit of distance and that one and like,
like that was real close.
That's kind of weird.
And I'm trying to just,
you know,
we wake up and cash is,
yeah,
they hit the,
hit us.
I go,
what the,
what are you talking about?
Why would he and I looked down from our sniper position to where the vehicles
were and that's what exactly what had happened.
And on my mind,
I know what an eight,
10 strike does.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he killed all my friends.
Yeah.
And then through the dust.
And so right away I'm like,
okay,
well if I'm the enemy,
I know what I would do.
D you know,
sound the bugles boys were attacking,
they didn't do that.
I,
my theory is they had already left for the after the gun fight the day before.
And so we re reorientate all our focus to the front to keep an eye on the enemy.
And I,
and I can't help but look down,
we had a,
a GTF a sniper team directly to our left and they left their a spotters in place
and the rest of them ran down with their medical kits and uh,
yeah.
And when they were walking away,
eventually the,
the,
the team,
you know,
four guys walk away with a body bag and I'm like,
oh,
okay,
that's it.
And then the,
you know,
the radio,
then,
then it's like,
yeah,
we're at 10,
10 wounded,
okay.
To 12.
Okay.
17 is 21.
And then I think we ended up at about 34,
35 or so,
and the entire leadership of the company is wiped out,
uh,
with injury.
And,
uh,
and that's it.
That company is now combat ineffective.
Yeah.
Which is the idea here that in the modern day you don't hear that very often.
Combat effective meaning that they can no longer perform their duties and you
just don't hear that.
They just didn't have enough bodies left.
Like they just didn't have enough soldiers that were still functioning.
Okay.
And
you know,
we went to Afghanistan in 2002 with a op was that Anaconda I believe we sent a
battalion of,
of Canadian soldiers with,
um,
and that's where the Canadian snipers set the new record beating Carlos half
Kochs that had stood since Vietnam.
And um,
but part of that mission was we lost four guys to in American have 16 and then
this happened and people give,
give a lot of shit to the American Air Force or,
or aircraft
mistakes happen.
We almost got lit up by our own guys at the,
of the assault.
You know,
we didn't talk about it,
but I had to radio in and weave and remind them,
hey guys,
we're coming in from your flank.
You've looked through thermal.
I've looked through thermal to guys like us look anything like bad guys looking
in through thermal.
I don't know how it happens.
Yeah.
But guys get so amped up and they're so ready to kill something.
You just don't want it to be you.
In Ramadi,
there was incidents where Humvees engaged other Humvees,
right?
Because the enemy does it.
He looks like anything like a Humvee,
no more distinctive vehicle in the world.
In a home,
right?
Yeah.
Especially when you're in the military and,
but that's to your point,
that's the level of confusion and mayhem and chaos that happens.
And just the mentality of guys when they're scared and all of a sudden they see
muzzle flash and okay,
you know what?
Boom,
oh,
I see something over there.
Engage everything looks like an every shovel in someone's hand.
Looks like an eight k.
So I don't lay any blame on the American pilot that did this.
He was doing the job he was there to do and,
and,
and someone told them to do something and they key cued off the wrong puff of
smoke.
And that's what happened.
You know,
it was just a,
literally,
it was one of those,
each little action led to it.
Right.
You know,
from mark lighting the,
the garbage fire to,
to him coming over the mountain and the,
and the,
and the son is in his eyes.
Amen.
Shit happens.
A bunch of small mistakes that compound and not even mistakes.
A bunch of situational actions.
Yeah.
The compound in to a tragic situation.
But when you consider what a strafing run from an eight 10 can do for us to only
have one killed is amazing,
is incredible.
And,
and only,
you know,
have those 30 something wounded.
I might not have the right number,
but if I understand correctly,
maybe a dozen of them had to retire due to their injuries.
Maybe crazy.
Yeah.
So you guys continue doing sniper operations.
You guys continue.
Okay.
Going on missions,
you support NSF,
you support others,
lots of really solid missions.
And now you're out on another operation.
You're patrolling through a village.
And again,
it's your,
your team that you've been with the whole time.
You're following cache your boy cash.
Hmm.
And I'm going to go to the book here.
Once he was about 10 meters ahead,
I turned and took my first step forward.
Yeah,
my right foot touch the ground at a orange fireball
soared across my face.
I didn't hear a sound for a few seconds.
I felt weightless as if I was suspended in fit in space.
The next thing I knew,
I was on the ground.
My ears,
nose and mouth tasted like mud
and that's when the pain hit the pain so intense that it completely overwhelmed
my body and my silence.
I started punching the ground and screaming,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
It was the only time in my life I've ever uttered anything religious.
The blast was so powerful that he had knocked cash down and I saw him in the
dirt up ahead of me for a few seconds.
I couldn't see barrier.
Gord,
they'd probably done what good snipers are supposed to do upon hearing the
explosion run for cover and prepare for an ambush.
A few seconds later,
once they realized what had happened,
they came running back towards me.
So there it is.
Did you know,
did you know it was an id?
Um,
not,
could been.
RPG can be somebody for those either.
Don't know.
You don't know.
Big booms are going off.
I,
I didn't hear anything.
Right.
Like I said,
like the,
the,
you,
you're not going to hear the one that gets you from,
in my case it was real,
but my hearing was fine.
There's no ringing.
There was no,
and I've read,
um,
colonel,
help me out.
He wrote on killing.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Anyway,
so I know your name.
I just,
I just forget it right now.
Uh,
and he's talks about that and his other book on combat.
Yeah,
the little audible,
the body will shut it off and the split second.
But anyway,
I knew I'd done something,
something bad had happened once.
I,
you know,
my weapon was gone.
You know,
my night vision is gone.
Right.
And the pain was so bad.
And you know,
it technically was an IED though under the technical definition,
right?
Cause it was an anti personal landmine on top of a mortar bomb.
Technically we you and I know that's an IED,
but it's really to conventional munitions put together and it did exactly what
it was supposed to do.
You know?
Um,
it just,
uh,
it's one of those,
it's one of those things of war where there's no rhyme or reason about who's
going to get what or when or where.
Cause everyone else in your patrol just walked over it.
I was the last guy,
I remember the first time,
first time I was ever getting shot,
I was in these and I'm going over a bridge in Baghdad.
And again,
this is going back to what you were talking about liquid.
You don't really know what's Kombat's like.
Yeah.
And I'm looking up ahead of me at the Humvee ahead of me and I see these,
like someone's throwing cigarettes out the window and I go,
who the hell is smoking?
We don't even have any like who's smoking?
Right.
And how are they smoking a thousand cigarettes and smoking so many cigarettes
right now.
And then why are there smoke?
Who wait,
why are these things spark and when they hit the the ground over there and why
is there sparks Oh,
okay.
Newsflash,
we're getting shot at or under effective fire.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's one of those things,
but my point is that you don't always know what,
what's happening.
And you know,
in the urban environment you didn't know where shots were coming for.
You get your like rounds,
we'll be going over head.
You could not tell where they were coming from.
Yeah.
You know,
if they're hitting something,
you can kind of get a general idea,
but you don't always know what's happening.
And all right,
so now going back to the book here,
my mates were all around me.
Now
the next hour was the longest of my life.
I was in absolute agony,
agony at trying hard to stay positive.
I was also trying hard not to think about the possibility of bleeding out with
each passing minute.
I was growing weaker and weaker.
Every time I close my eyes,
it was harder to open them again.
I knew that if I lost consciousness,
it was over bearing Gord.
We're standing over me.
Do you think I'm going to make it?
I ask Gord,
of course you gotta make it never give up bro.
You know that
and you guys hadn't been to t triple c,
none of us.
Ah,
so for those that you don't know,
there's something called t triple c tactical combat casualty care.
It's a very short course.
You had to like maybe a week,
it's two days,
maybe three days because all the,
all they teach you is how to keep somebody alive when this stuff happens.
That's what the goal is.
And it doesn't take a super amount of knowledge.
It takes some,
some concepts.
Number one,
stop the bleeding and,
but none of your guys had been to it,
but they still saved your life.
I mean,
between Barry Gordon,
I
like we're all experienced,
operate,
right?
And uh,
we still have enough first aid training.
You know,
the first thing they did is slapped the tourniquets on there.
You go at the,
at the arteries in my thighs and um,
and then they did their best from there and were snipers were not medics.
And we don't bring as awesome as medics are there kind of in the way when you're
on a sneaky,
sneaky mission,
you know?
Yeah.
That was what we,
that's how we classified our missions.
If they were sneaky,
sneaky
years,
really sneaky.
Sneaky.
If we're really sneaky,
sneaky with someone's going to have a bad day.
And this one was a middle sneaky and,
and,
and uh,
we were in a spot where there is no Lz.
You're not getting a vehicle in there.
Um,
you know,
and the closest medic was a 12,
1500 meters away on foot at night through an Afghan village.
Ours took them an hour.
The recky platoon just throwing this out there that they just gave,
they just didn't even wait for orders.
They are just common.
I love those guys.
That's why,
that's why I knew I had to say I love those guys.
Everyone at any one of them that listens.
I love those guys.
100%.
I'd do anything for them.
So
they get you,
they do get you out.
Yep.
Day.
They put the phone in your hand before you go into surgery.
Right.
So we're back in Canda,
her at the hospital and someone hands me a phone and uh,
I forget how it even went.
Like I was on a lot of drugs by this point.
One thing I will get wounded is get,
do a lot of good drugs.
Um,
here's what you told your dad.
Yeah,
they got me dad,
the Taliban,
but I'm alive going into surgery.
I'm going to get through this.
Don't worry.
I kind of want to compliment you right now.
Hmm.
Because you always hear of an up three Scully complimenting like all my buddies,
anybody had no that got wounded.
They're like,
hey,
don't worry about it.
I would be okay.
Yeah.
And
at the same time
you called your dad like dad wounded up,
go to the surgery.
Don't worry about,
you know,
uh,
that's,
that's all good.
Actually,
what's funny is Mikey Monsoor,
who was one of my guys got killed in Ramadi and I mean,
they were in grueling sustained combat every single day.
Firefights I mean,
he went Winchester on his,
on his heavy machine gun so many times that I don't even know.
Like one time I,
I was,
went to visit him in their campus.
I was on the other side of town,
Winchester beans,
completely out of Ammo,
sorry,
Winchester be drought ammo.
So I went to see,
I went to his camp pretty early in deployment,
maybe three or four weeks in deployment.
And I went over to their camp to see how things were going.
And someone's like,
oh,
go check out the video that Mike he made.
And I go,
okay,
cool.
And Mike,
he shows me this video and it's like a firefight happening.
Yeah.
And he's filming,
he's putting to the stick in the camera up above the the wall.
And then he turns it back on himself and he,
and he says the name of the part town that they were fighting in,
what's called them a lob district.
It might be towards the camera at himself.
And he goes,
it's the moon.
And so I'm looking at him laughing and then,
you know,
me being Mr professional and I go,
hey man,
and he's a new guy,
right.
And,
um,
you know,
Jocko,
I'm sorry,
go.
Hey Man,
what are you doing filming when there's a firefight going on.
I know you need to get your gun up.
Like I don't want to see this again.
And he's like,
hey,
sorry sir.
But I was Winchester and I go,
all right man.
That's all you got left be the history of be the document guy.
And just like in my opinion to go Winchester for an for a seal if he's anything
like,
uh,
like our machine gunners.
Yeah.
That's pretty tough to do.
Oh yeah.
It's not like Mike,
he wasn't carrying a tone around.
Like I said,
my point of telling this story was that,
you know,
this was happening on a fairly regular basis.
Definitely firefighter.
He wasn't going Winchester all the time,
but he didn't know.
But I'm just saying like old times and he was in,
you know,
almost daily firefighters.
Right.
I remember that.
This is an actual number.
So the first 24 operations that,
that element went on in a row.
They got into a firefight in the city.
Yeah.
And then they had one where they didn't and then they went right back to it
again.
So they were getting a lot of firefights and in a lot of danger.
And,
um,
when we got home,
when I got home,
but I,
and I got to know his family a little bit,
you know,
his,
his family was saying that when he'd call,
they'd be like,
what are you doing over there?
And he'd say,
Oh,
we're,
we're just training some Iraqi soldiers.
Yeah.
We're just on base.
It just,
you know,
don't worry about anything.
It's just fine.
Typical combat soldiers,
right.
Stories to the family.
Typical bad ass.
So that reminds me if you,
uh,
don't worry about it yet,
but it just got blown up.
Yeah.
Um,
then
here we go.
I woke up with a doctor looming over me,
took a few moments for the anesthetics to wear off and for me to remember where
I was and what was going on.
Then it came back to me in a rush.
The mission,
the landmine,
the pain,
the surgery,
the surgeon standing by my bed,
put it to me bluntly.
I had to cut off both your feet.
Boom.
I believe earlier we were talking about irreversible situations.
Yup.
And here you were,
was that real to you at that time
or were you basically,
hey,
I'm happy I'm alive.
I got to see your buddy that
got blown up.
Yeah.
And uh,
and actually you can get bonus.
Got Shot.
And um,
anyways,
one of my buddies was talking to him and he's like,
Bro,
man,
um,
I'm really sorry about,
you know,
he,
cause he lost his leg.
He was wrong,
man,
I'm really sorry about your leg,
you know,
and he goes,
fuck my leg.
I'm happy to be alive.
And I gotta be honest,
I didn't think that,
yeah,
I'm soldiering has done on your feet.
And I immediately went into defensive mode.
I,
um,
half my brain said,
you tell that fucking guy to go back and get that one of the feet
and put it back.
And the other half is saying he's a pro.
He knows what he's doing.
If he took it,
cause we knew one was gone on the scene,
that was the one that didn't needed the device.
The landmine did exactly what it's supposed to do.
It took,
blew my foot off the mortar bombs,
shredded my other foot.
And on the scene,
I remember as I was getting put onto the stretcher and getting put onto the
ambulance,
that was finally able to get to us because they literally plowed a road to me
with a combat bulldozer and had the ambulance behind it.
Um,
the medic from Ricky platoon and said,
hey man,
your left foot,
we got it back into place.
So it looks like it might be okay.
So,
uh,
but your right foot's gone.
And I was like,
okay,
whatever.
And again,
at this point I'm like so out of it.
So when I woke up and he says,
yeah,
you know,
I had to take both feet.
Huh.
Hm.
And,
and the,
in my mind I'm thinking like,
well,
how am I gonna,
how am I going to do this job?
Okay.
And then,
so then I go into Def,
uh,
the,
you know,
depending on who's manual you're reading or which doctor wrote it,
there's certain number of steps to a grieving.
And they say losing a part of body part is like losing a family member or
something.
So now I'm dealing with two deaths in the family and the first step is always
denial and you know,
and I'm like,
oh,
it was 2007,
you know how awesome,
you know,
guys are going to be jealous.
I had my legs blown off.
I'm going to be like,
rob,
I'm going to be like astro boy,
be flying around and shit,
I'll have like robocop legs or something.
It's cool.
It's 2007.
Right?
Everything's digital.
Um,
and I kind of,
whether it was the drugs and,
or the endorphins from going through all that,
and,
but for that first,
until I was out of Kandahar,
that was my attitude,
you know,
right up to the boys all came in to see me off.
Cause we went from,
so I think I spent another day in Kandahar.
They flew me to bag room and then I flew to Kuwait and then from Kuwait on to
Germany.
Yeah.
But a Lanch to orchestra hall.
And so every,
every stop that we picked up wounded American servicemen.
And,
uh,
and,
I think there was one other Canadian,
but,
so I just,
you know,
that's how I felt.
Right.
And then,
and then once I was in Germany,
um,
okay.
I was just trying to deal with every day by day,
you know.
Um,
I just was,
you know,
they put me in a room with another guy who had been hit in an IED strike on a,
on a,
so a lav you,
you were saying Lav earlier.
So those are the Marine Corps.
The Marine Corps has an anachronism,
Lav.
So that's why I was calling it that.
But yeah,
it's,
so it's light armored vehicle.
And you guys in the army here,
they're called strikers.
Yeah.
Except ours have turrets and I think yours has like remote 50 cals or something.
They're all made in London,
Ontario,
Canada,
by the way.
Um,
so yeah,
I was just trying to deal with each day as,
as it can't,
cause now I'm it,
I've never,
there's no,
you can't,
there's no training for this.
Right.
And casualty simulation,
it stops once you're declared dead or evacuated.
Right.
So now I'm at a stage where I'm like,
okay,
I'm in a room with another Canadian dude,
um,
and an American Army hospital and uh,
I dunno what's next.
Yeah.
And every time I'd look down there's no toes to wiggle.
Yep.
It was just so I'm like,
okay,
well I'm just going to try and deal with this,
just deal with it,
just deal with it.
And I was in that mode at for for weeks.
Yeah.
I W I,
I think I was waiting for a point where someone was going to give me my
diagnosis,
you know,
or my,
the conclusion or like a prescription,
like,
okay,
here's what you're going to do now.
This is not just with your legs but with your life.
Yeah.
This is what's going to happen.
You're going to do this,
you're going to follow these steps and at the end you'll be deploying back to
Afghanistan,
which is how it was going in my mind,
you know,
I don't know what you're going to read next,
but I was convinced I'm going back out again.
Dan.
Huh?
That's it.
Like just,
okay.
That's it.
Whenever you know the navy or the army wants you to know something,
they send you on course.
So you know I was on sniper course and then you go on,
you're going to drive her chorus.
She go on tack tack to Combat Casualty Care Course t triple c.
So,
so as you're saying this,
that's actually the next portion.
Yeah,
I was going to look good.
Okay,
here you go.
Exactly what you were just about to get it from that point on,
I made it my mission to learn to walk again.
I treated rehab like a military course.
When the military wants a soldier to learn something,
they send them on a course.
So that's the approach I took with my rehab,
the mission mindset there.
But at the same time in now we start going into the fact that it was obvious
that the Miller Siri system,
the military system just couldn't quite cope with my needs.
Sure.
I was offered help with all sorts of things from rehab to finding a home,
but no one truly understood the needs that are particular to a returning
soldier.
And neither did I.
No.
So you didn't even know.
I mean,
how do you know that?
But that's what I'm saying.
How can,
you know?
There's no course description,
there's no course,
there's no training,
you know,
and our military medical system was like,
like the,
we have lots of medics,
we have doctors for things like sprained ankles and,
and,
and uh,
you know,
you hurt your back on a ruck march,
whatever,
whatever.
Lots of guys and girls that do that.
No.
You know,
our physiotherapy,
we've got physio therapists,
but they've been dealing with tennis elbow and sprained ankles for 40 years.
And it's no detriment to them.
It's not their fault.
It's,
um,
they've just,
that's the military that they were in.
And you compare that in the book.
You talk about when you went to the center for intrepid in San Antonio and now
you had the American system,
which has been,
yeah,
unfortunately dealing with thousands and thousands and thousands of wounded
soldiers for at that point,
I guess for you guys,
about four or five years.
Okay.
Four or five years.
Well,
it was,
oh well,
oh seven.
Yeah,
I guess you guys started an old one right after that.
Yup.
I don't know whoever,
whenever the guys first went in after the towers dropped and so they had
experience and they have giant amount of money.
I mean this is America and we do have a lot of money and they put a lot of money
into it.
And,
and at the same time you had some Canadian folks that were like,
oh,
we don't need that kind of stuff.
You don't need those kinds of things for rehab.
Right,
right.
Well,
again,
I'm,
you know,
we have,
I'm trying to think of a correlation here,
but anyway,
we had these physiotherapists.
It's a trade in the military.
You're a military physiotherapist and your job is to rehab guys like me and I'm
telling you,
you can't do it.
Or I'm telling you that you're failing and this is why.
So what your reaction is going to be?
Well,
I know how to do my job and I don't.
So I don't,
at the time I was furious.
In retrospect,
they didn't know any better.
And that's why I started advocating so hard.
I,
I s I got,
cause I got home and I said this is what we got to do.
There's not that many guys like me coming home.
I mean yeah,
there's a lot more than there were last year because we're actually at war.
The Center for the intrepid,
Walter Reed and I believe one here.
The naval medical is medical center about bow and there's Bethesda as well.
So,
uh,
well I've heard of three San Antonio,
Walter Reed and the one here.
Those are the biggies.
Those are the ones where most of the traumatic injuries have been going from,
from the,
from,
from you guys.
So I said,
let's start sending a pair of physiotherapists down with like for every
physiotherapist we send down or for every two casualties we send down,
let's send down one of our physiotherapist and six months that physiotherapist
will get more experience dealing with more injuries at,
with more patients than they could ever hope for.
Onbase.
Petawawa where two brigade is,
cause we're talking the difference between a couple of dozen soldiers getting
hurt,
playing rugby or whatever or ruck marching versus actually uh yeah,
like a parade of guys get who are getting smashed in IED strikes and you know,
whatever was happening.
You know,
I was standing there and the guy who ran Antonio at the San Antonio at the time
was,
he was in Greenbrae physiotherapists,
so I don't know if he was one and then the other or how it worked.
But so he's the lead physical therapist.
And I remember this marine walked in to the,
to the room and he had both legs gone above the knee.
So he's on the taller leg,
prosthetics and I,
and he was blinded by it cause he had been burned or whatever.
And the,
and this guy,
he's in full uniform,
he likes screams the guy's name,
he's like Jones.
And he tackles him and they start wrestling.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I want that.
Because the hospital I was in,
and again,
no offense to the hospital,
I got great medical care
for the standard,
right to their capability,
their capabilities at that time.
And it's not like it was bad,
but it wasn't what would have been best for me.
Me being a soldier.
So I'm like,
cause I'm in the hospital where it's knee and hip replacements and amputations
from diabetes.
So it was a lot of older people.
Um,
I was probably one of the youngest people in the hospital at 30.
I was definitely in the best shape.
You know,
like I remember the first physiotherapy session,
she hands me a four pound beanbag weight with a strap on it.
And she says,
oh a strap that around your leg and you know,
try and do like,
you know,
maybe,
maybe 15 or 20 a leg raises if you think you can.
And I'm like,
where's the squat rack?
So I strapped,
I'm like four pounds,
is that enough?
And she's like,
Oh yeah,
we don't want to start too hard.
Nice sweet lady,
great person.
I loved her the best.
She can,
she knows she's doing what she knows.
I strapped the thing to my stump and I started doing leg raises and she comes
back like 10 minutes later.
She's like,
so how many did you get done?
I'm like,
I don't know,
maybe 250.
Right?
She's like,
Oh,
oh.
And I'm like,
yeah,
like I'm,
I'm in,
I'm in shape.
It was just meat and bone smashed.
Like,
I don't have any other injuries here,
but dare at San Antonio,
the lead therapist is tackling and wrestling with a blind legless marine.
And I'm like,
that's what I need.
I need to be around soldiers and people who know how I think and uh,
I can't help again and I'm not trying to criticize or,
or,
or be overly,
um,
detrimental to the results of what came.
But imagine if I had had that treatment.
What,
you know,
people would say,
oh,
Jody,
you did fine.
You did great.
You're the poster boy.
Imagine if I had been in San Antonio,
you know,
where could have eight faster,
you think not,
well,
the level of expectation where I was was very,
very low.
So they didn't like,
so if I had been at San Antonio,
they'd be like,
no,
you will be walking by March.
You will do this and you,
whereas where I was,
because that's how they do it.
That's like,
well we'll see where you're at.
You know,
and this and that and that.
And there was no,
there's no one for me to mentor under or be,
you know,
like there's no one to be compared to or to be comparative.
Look at this guy over here.
He's grappling with another dude even though he's blind,
he's missing a leg.
Yeah.
And Are you ready to get it on?
You know,
another guy came in,
I think he was a marine too,
and he was wearing a,
it's just like a tee shirt and the same guy's like,
hey,
where's your issue PT kit?
The Marine Corps doesn't play around and well this was the green baret guy.
Right.
But he's,
but Roger,
cause they're all,
it's a mixed force,
right?
There's air force,
Navy,
marine,
whoever's there,
there was a,
there was a navy,
I believe she was navy EOD.
You'd had her arms blown off and she was recently in that range.
15 movie.
I think it's the same girl.
I've only met one girl who had both her arms blown off by,
by uh,
by an IED.
But so I imagine it's her.
But anyway,
um,
he expected you to be a soldier regardless of what happened to you.
You're going to maintain that persona son.
And I was like,
yeah,
cause I could feel myself slipping at this other place because there's no
expectations,
you know,
and you can only self mode.
And
having never had my legs blown off before,
I could only me self motivate to a point for so long and,
and,
and be the guy beat with my own drill sergeant and be my own,
uh,
inspector.
And there,
there's a reason,
and I say this all the time,
there's a reason why the best athletes in the world have coaches.
Yeah.
That's the fact.
It's because somebody has got to show you the way.
Yeah.
And you can.
And furthermore,
you can only push
yourself so hard.
I know for a fact you can only push yourself to 107% a coach is going to get you
to 117% they can push you a little bit harder.
Now,
I have no mercy.
And so that's what you need.
That's what everybody,
yeah.
You know,
and so,
but
again,
I try to give credit where credit's due and give,
you know,
people were worried when I wrote the book,
there were people I heard that we're worried and I'm not,
I don't want to shit on anyone and I don't want it to seem like I'm blaming
anyone for anything.
I put myself there.
I'm the one that wanted to be in that spot to step on that landmine.
My only expectation was that others would have put the preparation into their
mission as I put into mine.
And I do feel that there were some at very high levels that maybe didn't take
things as seriously as they should have or realized the consequences of what was
coming and take best practices from places like Walter Reed,
San Antonio.
Because when I said,
send me to San Antonio and send a Canadian physiotherapist with me and she,
he or she's going to learn in the three or six months,
I'm there more than she will in 20 years at any Canadian base.
It was,
oh,
well,
we appreciate that Mitak but you know,
we're,
we're working on a Canadian solution,
and I was like,
well,
that's going to be awesome once you figure out whatever the fuck that is.
What about me?
I'm talking about right this second.
We have a facility willing to take us to,
did they send pts down there?
No,
because here's,
here's the backroom stuff.
The politics.
Jodie,
what would the civilians thing if we were sending our soldiers to a different
country's medical centers
when we got hospitals right here.
Now again,
what we were getting at the hospital was not bad care.
You know what I'm saying?
You do.
You understand the distinction.
Okay.
It was,
it was the best care to the capability and the knowledge and understanding that
they had not only of their job,
but of the people that they were working with.
Yeah.
In other words you got,
if you got a 72 year old diabetic that has an amputation,
the four pound weight is good and that you can try and transfer that over to
Jody medic who just got off the battlefield three weeks ago.
Yeah,
he's a different animal.
Yeah.
Option two,
right to like what they,
but they're trained and what they're really good at caring for.
You come in and this is like,
this isn't really typical that we all have to deal with.
Why are we going to change our whole system?
Well,
yeah,
exactly that,
but even things like,
I remember the first couple of nurses that came into my room,
they're like,
oh hey honey,
what happens to what the car accident?
Were you on a motorcycle?
You're on a mode really well,
losing your foot is very typical of a motorcycle accident,
but they didn't,
and I'm like,
oh,
I,
I stepped on a landmine in Afghanistan.
We even have soldiers in Afghanistan.
And I was like,
ah.
So hence,
hence this part of the book.
Ironically,
one of the biggest emotional problems I had to deal with was the anger.
I felt towards a medical system that did not seem to be able to respond
appropriately to my needs.
Yeah.
Now you ended up putting on weight cause you couldn't exercise and you do give a
little shout out right here to the dairy queen.
Dairy Queen is delicious when you're depressed.
Oh,
it's so good.
It's so good.
Once it the lips,
it's a peanut butter cups and it's a swirly ice cream.
I might have to get one right after this.
Jocko,
you're gonna have to find a dairy queen
up in here.
Uh,
so in conjunction with the therapy sessions,
I also started taking an antidepressant to start to help control my moods.
And then there was the other kind of pain,
the physical kind.
I was still using painkillers to dull the pain that was there each and every
day.
I needed that relief so badly,
but in the end that to caused me tremendous suffering and I turned into
something I never thought I would be an addict.
We've definitely are seeing this happen with our wounded veterans.
And here you go.
In no time.
I was taking more of the drug that I was supposed to in order to relieve my
psychological and physical pain.
The addiction worsened and I started crushing the pills into a powder and
snorting it to get a better high.
Those pills gave me relief from my stress and mental pain,
if only for a little while.
But as soon as they wore off,
my demons would return.
I worried about my future
if I wasn't a soldier.
Who was I?
And you've already said that a bunch of times.
That feeling of,
I mean in it,
everything you'd been in your life from when you were a kid,
that was what was inside of you.
And then you were able to act on that and become that soldier,
serve in combat,
get after it on the battlefield.
My whole adult life,
I became a man in the military.
I joined as a 17 year old,
174 pounds,
six foot four skinny weakling.
And I grew into the,
into the man that you see.
And
in that question,
you know,
when I was reading that,
when,
you know,
I had a buddy that uh,
retired the other day,
25 years
and I just said to him,
I said,
how was it cleaned out your locker,
because I don't know what it's like for you guys,
but in the seal teams you have a locker and that's your whole career is
physically represented and the walkers are big.
They're there,
they're walking lockers,
they're awesome.
Oh Wow.
Each guy has a walking locker,
has a big dry calm,
a dry and gauge calm cages.
Cause there's just made with a chain link based material.
Basically each guy has,
everybody has their own,
they're almost as big as this office.
Right,
right,
right.
And you got crews,
boxes in there and it's your whole career is physically representative.
Everything you've ever been issued,
anything that you've picked up along the way,
trinkets,
just everything is in your drying gauge.
Right.
And when you retire,
you go,
you clean out your cage,
it's empty,
you sweep out the floor,
you floated into your van,
you drive home and that's it.
It's over.
Yeah.
And I,
so I said to my buddy the other,
I said,
you know,
how was it,
uh,
how was it cleaned out your drying cage?
Cause I that for me,
I wasn't even worried about retiring and you think about resigned.
I'm like,
okay,
I got to go do this,
go do the ceremony.
I'm all good.
Come back cleaning out my cage.
And I'm like,
oh this is over.
And for me,
I spent 18 out of 20 years out here on the west coast and all within like a
stone's throw of the different buildings.
I mean all within these certain number of buildings.
Yeah.
Since I was a kid.
Yep.
And the question,
so when I was reading that you wrote this,
that's what I was thinking about a what my buddy was thinking,
if I'm not a soldier,
if I'm not a seal,
then what am I?
That's a tough question to answer for it.
Audit guys,
brutal.
And it comes back to what we were talking about before,
dwelling right
eye.
It was really hard for me because I didn't choose to leave.
Right.
I'd always imagined I'd be,
you wounded.
I don't know why.
Like,
you know,
visual visualization is very important in my opinion,
in our line of work.
And so I'd always tried to,
you know,
envision,
uh,
being wounded.
Okay.
But it was like the cool scar across the cheek or like some shrapnel in the rib
cage.
I could show off at barbecues,
you know,
and talk about when I'm like 80,
I'd be like,
yeah,
I still got some Taliban metal in there.
But no,
you know,
like it's that or it's a body bag.
You don't think about the in between even our system.
Right.
Our medical system in Canada between lots of body bags,
lots of bandages,
but the,
in between part,
they kind of dropped the ball.
Yeah.
And years ago,
World War One,
probably World War II,
you wouldn't have made it.
They wouldn't have to deal with,
you know,
because you would have bled out.
They didn't know t triple C,
they wouldn't have gotten the CAS evac.
I mean,
it would've been,
you would've died.
That's all there is to double.
Yeah.
Double amputation.
Forget about,
uh,
so they just didn't have that back then.
Vietnam.
I've got a lot better in terms of the CAS evac situations to get helicopters in
there a lot faster.
That's why you need a lot more rude,
but yeah,
figuring out what you're going to do next and you held onto it,
you held onto it.
You tried to hang on to it because you decided,
you know what,
I'm going to still be a soldier.
Yeah.
You got done with,
he did a half marathon.
Yeah.
But after that half marathon,
you were just to beat up.
Yeah.
From that.
And you decided
that,
well,
here's what you put in the book.
I tell people that Jody,
the soldier was wounded in January of 2007 but it took them about two years to
die,
to let the soldier in you.
Yeah.
Go,
okay,
and I'm going to continue.
Of course,
this wasn't an easy decision for me,
and I was filled with rage and anger,
and again,
I started using Oxycontin as a relief from the pain of loss.
It became my problem yet again,
but I diluted myself into believing I had it under my control.
You talk about this thing where you're reading a reader's digest article.
Yeah.
And there's an oxycontin addict in there.
And he's talking about how he's shooting it up.
And you said to yourself,
you weren't thinking,
oh,
that's,
that's horrible.
I can't believe you're like,
hm.
Well,
I didn't know you thought of that.
And that is what hits you.
Yeah.
And I think
that is what hits you realizing that's when you realize you weren't control.
Right.
I mean,
that's gotta be that moment because it is the story where he was a doctor,
I believe,
right.
Injecting himself in the bathroom when his young daughter walked in.
And I had now had a young daughter
and I could just,
and now I'm like,
and I,
and in my mind it wasn't,
oh,
imagine if my daughter caught me going to eject.
I went,
oh,
I can inject.
And I remember,
and I even went through a second where I remembered how great it was to get the
intervenous drugs in the hospital.
And then the next second was,
oh,
this is not good.
This is not good.
And then when I ended up buying,
um,
I ended up buying Percocet,
which is like Oxycontin,
but like from a guy that I knew through another guy and it was,
they were in Ziploc bags,
basically a drug deal.
You remember that thing that got me arrested 20 years ago
and I,
okay,
this is,
this is it.
This ends here.
Well,
that's an awesome,
I mean,
that's awesome credit to you on that because so many people,
unfortunately they don't take ownership of that.
They don't say to themselves,
you know what?
I am addicted and this thing is controlling me.
And they always say things like,
just what you said,
ah,
I got this under control.
I can stop if I want to.
Just don't want,
I need it.
I'm in pain there.
He'd go.
I had to take it and I would ask the doctors,
I would say,
how do we get,
how do we get me off this?
And this was still,
you know,
oh seven Oh eight nine I think it was 2011 before I finished or got off them.
They still have in Canada anyway,
hadn't realized what Oxycontin was a capable of and and so the dog was at,
it's like three days of withdrawals.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Those withdrawals were worse than being wounded.
Those three days.
Here's your quote.
Those
days were absolute horror.
Quitting oxycontin was harder and more painful than getting blown up in
Afghanistan.
Yeah,
because?
Because it was three days,
whereas I was in the worst Jocko Echo,
I cannot tell you what the pain was like cause it was so bad and that was the
pain from going from withdrawals.
No,
the pain from getting blown out.
Okay,
so the pain from getting cannot describe it to you,
but the withdrawals lasted three days of that kind of pain because your body and
your mind are trying to trick you or are you still in pain?
Man,
you still in pain.
You should take him,
you should take them.
But once,
you know what's funny though,
the three days,
it's almost like you hit a switch and suddenly the pain starts to dissipate.
The hollow feeling in your chest starts to fill back in.
The ant stopped crawling on your skin because that's,
you're going through all of that.
I was grinding the stumps of my legs into the coach to give it some kind of
other sensation other than I described it as like,
it was like a dog.
You ever watch a dog chew on a bone when he's got it between his paws and he's
just going to town with his teeth.
That's what it felt like on the ends of my legs was like I had like an animal
just gnawing on my legs
and then one day,
you know,
whatever,
the third or second,
two and a half for three days later I realized,
I'm like,
oh,
most of that's kind of pretty much gone.
It's crazy.
And uh,
I tell Ya,
there's Jody before he quit oxycotton and then there's Jody and Jody before he
quit was still trying his best and doing well.
And if you talk to anybody who was the guy,
a lot of people looked up to,
but you know,
things really started to turn around after I quit.
You know,
I really started to become capable of a lot in my,
in my mind,
I think there's a big difference.
But man,
that Shit,
just my buddy,
he is a,
he's a paratrooper and a,
he had to get some surgery on his knee,
you know,
paratroopers,
earlies banging up their knees and,
and the doctor gave him coding or of Tylenol three or something like that.
And he literally took it and threw it in the garbage.
He's like,
I saw what happened to Jody.
I just like,
I don't even,
I don't want anything.
And,
um,
that's my advice.
Kids out there do not take it.
If you don't,
if you can grit your teeth enough,
do not take that shit.
Stay clean,
do your best.
I wouldn't trust me around it.
Now if you had one,
I might take it.
I don't go good.
Let's just take some more of this Alpha brain.
Take the Alpha,
getting skin.
I'll get on it instead of,
instead of getting addicted again,
get
off it by getting on it.
Uh,
so now you get through it.
You're not addicted to oxycontin anymore.
And now it's what do I going to do with my life?
And here you go,
what did I actually want and what was possible and could I really put my
military past behind me and pursue something else that would make me feel
fulfilled?
But it was time to stop asking questions.
It was time to find some answers.
Okay,
and here you're kind of referring back and it's the last chapter.
Um,
it's called on my own two feet.
I'm glad you still got a sense of humor after all this.
Can't make fun of yourself,
man.
Take life way too serious.
So a lot of professional athletes will tell you they miss two things when they
retire.
The competition on the field and the camaraderie with the team,
late teammates in the locker room,
it's the exact same thing for soldiers after we leave the armed forces.
When I see soldiers on parade,
I still get chills down my spine because I loved it so much.
Yeah,
just letting everybody know that that's completely normal for all you guys that
got out for whatever reason.
Totally normal.
Jodie feels it.
I feel it.
We all feel that.
So then you went and did the amazing race in Canada.
Yeah,
we had the,
you got second place with your brother's second place,
and it was the first season because the American amazing race was the most
popular show in Canada.
So let's make a Canadian,
what's Mega Canadian one?
If Canadians love anything more than the American version,
it's the Canadian version.
Then you ended up doing this city counselor thing.
Yeah.
And
that's where you're at now.
That's where I'm at now.
You know when,
one part that we haven't talked about,
and I'm going to do it a little bit of a,
I'm going to score a few Brownie points here at home.
So I,
I said they had to plow a road to me yeah.
To,
to rescue me.
Right.
They literally plowed a road with a combat bulldozer.
And right behind it was what we call a buys,
an ambulance.
And it's an eight wield,
almost built in the same factory as the Lav in Ontario,
Canada,
London,
Ontario,
Canada by a unionized workers.
And,
uh,
and,
and the commander of that vehicle was master corporal Atlanta Gilmore of the
Canadian Forces Medical Corps,
who is now my wife,
retired sergeant Atlanta Gilmore of the Canadian Forces Medical Corp.
Um,
and we have two beautiful daughters,
ala seven and Kiera four.
And,
uh,
yeah,
we,
we managed to connect.
Yeah.
I was wounded in January.
We connected in September or Octoberish of the saint of 2007.
My girlfriend that I had had when I got wounded had left no fault of hers.
I don't blame her one one bit,
you know,
um,
to get thrown into a situation where you have to care for a wounded soldier,
the guy who before was like a rock,
you know,
and that's not what you signed up for.
Right.
And,
uh,
and Atlanta had recently broken up with it,
with,
with her partner as well.
And when we found each other though,
the fact that she was a hot Irish blonde was just really a bonus bonus.
Gotta be honest.
And,
and,
uh,
she took one,
you know,
Jocko,
I call medics,
they're like our mommies.
What do you guys have?
Corman.
You call them?
Yeah.
Cause see combat guys were a little low that saying,
if you're going to be tough,
you are,
if you're going to be dumb,
you gotta be tough.
You gotta be stupid.
You gotta be telling you yes.
And that's,
and that's us.
We need the corpsman or the medic to be like,
hey,
hey Jocko.
Why are you limping?
What?
Come here.
Come here,
dummy.
Come here.
No,
no,
not in front of the other troops.
Mom,
stop it.
Stop it.
And,
and so that's their job.
So she saw me,
she took one look at me.
She's like,
you look terrible.
I was surviving on vectors,
cereal and drive through sandwiches because I was by myself.
All the boys were still deployed or on course.
And I was living in my own private,
a house on base.
So I had moved on to base.
I had this little puppy,
uh,
Charlie who wasn't,
he's not a service dog by any stretch,
but he's the only reason I got it,
a bed in the morning.
So I owe him.
He's still my buddy still at that.
He's at the house right now.
And,
um,
and she,
so she went into medic mode.
Really?
She went,
you know what should come by my house,
bring your dog,
you can play with my dog and let's just hang out.
And when we got,
when,
when we saw each other though,
it was comradery.
She was one of the last people to see me on the battlefield.
She carried my stretcher to the,
to the,
to the EVAC chopper.
And you know,
if you talked to her,
the fact that I was,
you know,
uh,
a bearded hot guy was just a bonus to her too.
And you know,
eventually I let her kiss me guys.
Okay.
Passively,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Now she likes you.
She,
she's going to ask me,
did you tell Jocko the same joke you tell everyone else that Iq STIU
but when we got pregnant a little quick alias birthday's September.
Do the math.
So,
but you know,
we realized,
we talked about it.
When we talk about the survivor's guilt,
you don't,
you didn't survive,
you know,
your friends live for your friends.
I didn't survive and she didn't like her vehicle hit land mines and she was in
ambushes and all,
you know,
near near death on a battlefield is a bullet going an inch from your head.
That's near death.
Yeah.
You laugh about it after.
But that's,
so she was in all that too.
And so she's pregnant and I should have died and who knows what could happen to
her and who are we to deny what's happening,
you know,
so I have to,
I had to throw that out there that,
you know,
I have three beautiful blondes in my life with blue eyed blonds that,
uh,
keep me in check and cause I,
the,
the feelings I had in the book,
they're not all in the past.
You know,
I woke up yet yesterday when I missed the flight,
man,
it,
it was more that I was disappointing you.
Right.
And hear me out.
Because I was just like,
I was like,
I'm the city councilor and a lot of guys look up to me and this and that and all
that.
You,
I've got these kids and you know,
Atlanta and the,
and I still can't make a fucking flight,
you know,
and I haven't even met the guy yet and I'm already disappointed them.
And that went through me and it's all because I stepped on that stupid landmine,
but I wouldn't even be here if I had stepped on that landmine.
I wouldn't have had these,
I wouldn't have these kids if I hadn't stepped on a landmine after my second
fiance walked out of the house and my,
you know,
like all eyes,
that's my joke.
I like all good soldiers.
I have three x fiances and it doesn't ex-girlfriends sacrifice to the queen
because we still swear allegiance to the queen because it's real.
That's like you said,
the teams come first.
And uh,
I had said,
well,
I'm going to retire at about 44 with 25 years in,
so why don't I just start kids and all that then.
And I'm sure my life would be fine if I hadn't stepped on the landmine,
but would it be as fulfilling?
Would I be as,
as,
as deaf,
as broad or
would I be as complete?
I'm sure I'd be a kick ass spec ops sniper somewhere doing something,
but
I couldn't,
no matter,
like if,
if I had a wish to not step on the mine,
but I wouldn't get to keep the kids,
I'd step on that mind 10 times at a 10.
And,
um,
so I had to,
you know,
I had to throw it in there and give credit to Atlanta for what she did for me
and also my friends and family.
Right.
Just nobody does it.
No one's a rock,
you know.
So I,
I just had to say all that.
Yeah,
no.
And I actually,
uh,
I have a question about your wife and okay.
That was going to give you an opportunity to steal some of your thunder.
Not at all.
Uh,
I'm glad you,
I'm glad you put that out there.
And also I didn't want to steal thunder from your book.
Right.
And that was one of the things that I was going to tell people.
I mean,
obviously I think people are just gonna buy this.
I mean obviously got,
there's,
this is the a big book which I've taken some excerpts out of.
Yeah,
and there's so much more in it,
but when you read it and you get the whole,
the whole package,
one of which is you explaining these relationships with your wife,
with your kids and how that happened,
which is just a,
I mean for all practical purposes,
let's just call it what it is.
That's a miracle.
Yeah.
Here's how it closes out.
People often ask me if I regret my time in Afghanistan because it costs me my
two feet and completely changed my life.
If you live your life with regrets,
then you never move forward.
Yeah.
Those six months in Afghanistan before the explosion where some of the best
times of my life,
I can honestly say as I look back on my life in the military,
I wouldn't have changed a thing if I hadn't stepped on that landmine.
I would never have connected with Alana.
I would never have had two beautiful daughters.
My mind and body were pushed to the limit after my accident.
And ironically I came out on the other side,
a better,
more complete person.
Maybe life would be easier now if I hadn't lost a part of both legs,
but it certainly wouldn't have been any more complete
when I want,
when I am in public today,
advocating for veteran's rights are simply going about my daily life.
People sometimes approach me to say thank you for your service.
Those five words mean more to me than anything else.
Now I'd like to say something,
Jodi,
from me,
and on behalf of every American Canadian,
Brit Australian,
and the rest of the free world,
thank you for your service
and your inspiration,
okay.
To all of us.
Okay.
To overcome obstacles and to make a difference in the world.
Thank you.
Thank you man.
And you got a tear in my IRA now.
Don't do it.
You're on youtube.
No doubt.
Thank you.
[inaudible] thank you too for your service.
Don't thank me
and I think that's going to be enough for tonight.
So
if you haven't got this feeling yet,
you're listening to the podcast.
Okay.
I know you're going to want to go out and get this book.
It's called unflinching,
the making of a Canadian sniper by my man right here,
Jody medic.
It's,
it's what you want to read about.
That's right.
And you can get it anywhere.
Books are bought.
You can get it on Amazon.
I recommend for my American cousins use Amazon through a,
what is it,
the Jocko podcast or the Jocko store.
He wants to go through Jocko store.
I like your recommendations there.
Go to the Jocko store,
click on the Amazon link.
So Jocko gets a little piece of a,
of the pie.
The paperback is out so you save a few bucks and uh,
be an honor to,
uh,
to have you guys read my book.
If you,
uh,
you're on social media.
The web,
I do the webs or web,
Jody Mitic and j.
O.
D.
Y,
M.
I t I see on Twitter,
Instagram,
snapchat and Facebook.
Snapchat.
I have no idea.
So chapter six,
evidently everybody uses it.
Jody Mitic.
Yeah,
I'm on snap it people use it.
Okay.
Um,
well I'm convinced it was it not going to judge.
Okay.
Not going to judge.
Um,
yeah,
I don't hide Jody Mitic on Instagram,
Facebook,
Twitter,
and for all you 14 year olds out there,
you can get him on snapchat.
Hey,
the 14 year olds need to hear this.
That's true.
Actually.
You probably need to hear it.
She didn't know.
So snapchat is,
you can come in like a real friend.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think it originated as that kind of where it's like,
Hey,
let me send you this.
Isn't this kind of cool undercover and it goes away.
He convinced it was a dick pic.
You're sending Dick.
Yeah.
and whatnot.
And then someone found a legit way to network or some,
that's a real deal.
Now I will certainly,
the rock is on the snapchats.
Right on,
right on
an honor,
sir.
Um,
I,
um,
the chances of me being here tonight are,
are,
are very limited.
We have Twitter to thank literally one of my fans and one of your fans,
basically head head locked us on Twitter and made us talk to each other.
And uh,
and I became a fan when you were on the rogue and show and podcasting,
you know,
we talked a little bit at lunch.
It really helped me when I was going through some rough times and you know,
I want to thank you for letting me come down here to this beautiful city and do
this for me.
And um,
you know,
thank you for writing your book and being who you are and an echo.
Thanks for,
for helping him make this happen.
And you know,
I got a podcast,
I'm starting the Jody Mitic podcast and a,
there may or may not be an episode up,
uh,
and the next couple of days,
but if people want to look for me there as well,
I'd be honored to try and entertain them as closely as you do.
And,
uh,
and as,
as all the other podcasts I love do.
And you know,
I just do this to try and be me.
You know,
I don't know who the new Jody mitigators,
I call him.
I'm calling myself Jodi 3.0 right now.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
and this life is a trip.
You know,
I call myself a student of the human condition and I'm always learning.
I'm always learning and I,
and I love to meet New People and um,
yeah,
that's all I want to say right now,
man.
I appreciate this a lot.
You have no idea.
Well,
we appreciate everything that you've done.
As I've already said to everybody else out there that's less than,
I think we're going to actually continue this on and we're going to go to a Q
and a on the next podcast and we'll just roll that out afterwards.
But for right now and for this evening,
I think that's about all we've got.
So everyone that's out there that listen to this,
that knows that a person can go to some depths,
I could climb right back out of those depths,
get out there
and get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jody and Jocko
out.